TO ORDER HI GOOD MORNING. BY
RESPONSE THE COVER NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC- FOR LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS I'M
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING A
FACE COVERING WERE GUIDELINES.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THESE ORDER
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
TO ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC
CONTINUES TO HAVE ACCESS. TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS IN A
SAFE WAY. MORE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY- TODAY-
WE HAVE ONE AUTHORED A CENTER
STERN. WHO IS TO DISCREDIT
REMOTELY CENTER STERN- IF YOU
HAVE A STAFF PERSON WITH YOU
COULD YOU PLEASE IDENTIFY THE
STAFFER NOW. YES MISTER CHAIR I
HAVE OF MY DISTRICT DIRECTOR
HERE IN OUR DISTRICT OFFICE
JEREMY WOLF IN A ROOM DOWN THE
HALL. GREAT THANK YOU ENATOR-
AS A REMINDER TO CENTERS TERM
PLEASE- MUTE YOUR PHONES OR
COMPUTERS- SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK- AND I
SAID EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
RECOGNIZE YOU YOU USE THE RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURE IN THE
PROGRAM- ALTHOUGH YOU'RE AN
AUTHOR. SO IF YOU WILL SO MAY
NOT BE DOING THAT- EACH TIME
THIS IS ME- TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC. TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY- TODAY- FOR
ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENTS. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT'LL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AT ALL
AN OUNCE AND NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE FIVE TWO. AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE ONE SEVEN FOUR
SEVEN SEVEN ONE. AND AGAIN YOU
CAN GO TO OUR WEB. FOR DETAILS
AND- WHEN WE MOVED PUBLIC
COMMENT YOU'LL BE PROMPTED BY A
MODERATOR TO DIAL ONE THEN ZERO
FOR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION.
PRESSES ONLY ONE TIME AND WAIT
PATIENTLY FOR AN OPERATOR TO
ASSIGN. YOU A LINE NUMBER- ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER.
YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR
THE MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU'LL BE
ON MUTED YOU'LL BE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON BEFORE YOU GIVE
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE.
OTHERWISE THERE WILL BE
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK AND IT MIGHT
BE HARD FOR US TO HEAR YOU- I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING
THE HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY.
AND THE INDIVIDUAL WHOSE
DESTRUCTIVE MAYBE REMOVE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE. OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTION NEEDED. WELL EVERY
EFFORT IS MADE TO STREAMLINE
THE HEARING PROCESS. AND
CONDUCT OUR HEARINGS AND IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LIFETIMES- DUE TOO. THE
TECHNOLOGY THAT WE'RE USING.
PLEASE BE RESPECTFUL AND
PATIENT. SO WE HAVE TWELVE
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA WHICH
WILL HERE AND FILE ORDER-
BEFORE WE HEAR OUR BILL
PRESENTATIONS WE WILL STOP THIS
QUORUM- WITH A CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
WINNER. PRESENT WINNER PRESENT
BATES HERE IT'S PRESENT CORTESE
YOUR CORTESE FURTHER CABALLERO.
COPYRIGHT PRESENT MCGUIRE WHAT
CHAU BOTH HERE THE JOB PRESENTS
SKINNER I'M HERE SKINNER
PRESENT NUMBER NUMBER PRESENT
WHAT KASKY. SEVEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM. WE WILL NOW PROCEED- TO
OUR- FIRST- BILL AND I WOULD
ALSO JUST NOTE- THAT WE HAD TO
HAVE A CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY
WHICH I SEE WHEN WE TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR NOW- THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS FILE ITEM
THREE WHICH IS A CA TO. FILE
AND FOR WHICH IS SB FIVE NINETY
ONE AND FILE NUMBER SIX- WHICH
IS SB SEVEN TO EIGHT- DO WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. MOTION BY SENATOR
CABALLERO- AND THEN FILTER WILL
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
WIENER. HI WIENER I'D SAY IT'S
HI BATES AYE CABALLERO AYE
CABALLERO AYE CORTEZ AYE
COURTESY AYE MCGUIRE. BUT CHAU
BOOK. THIS CAN SEND CALENDAR
YES I SUCH ARE SKINNER. SKINNER
I NUMBER. NUMBER I COUNTY.
SEVEN OKAY THAT HAS ENOUGH
VOTES WILL PUT ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS OKAY WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO- FILE NUMBER ONE WHICH
IS SB SIXTY THREE BY CENTER
STERN WHO'S WITH US REMOTELY
WELCOME SENATOR AND YOU MAY
PRESENT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
IN THE COMING THROUGH OKAY. YES
YOU ARE OKAY GREAT. THANK YOU-
MISTER CHAIR AND SAID YOU HAVE
SAID I JUST WANT TO MAKE CLEAR
THAT I ACCEPT AND APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS- WHICH
CLARIFY INSURANCE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE- THAT IT INVOLVES A
NEIGHBORING HOMEOWNERS PROPERTY-
A- SO EXCEPT THOSE AMENDMENTS
AND APPRECIATE THE
CLARIFICATION I'M MEMBERS THIS
SB SIXTY THREE IS A RE
INTRODUCTION OF A BILL LAST
YEAR THAT WE SPENT TWO YEARS
WORKING ON TO IMPROVE- THE
DURABILITY AND- RESILIENCE OF.
HOUSING AND OTHER DEVELOPMENT
THAT WE HAVE IN OUR VERY HIGH
HIGH AND MODERATE FIRE SEVERITY
ZONES- THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT
WE'RE WE'RE BUILDING WE KNOW
THAT THOSE DEBATES ON HOW LAND
USE POLICY IS GOING TO IMPACT-
WILDFIRE RISK AND WHILE WE TRY
TO TACKLE THE HOUSING CRISIS WE
KNOW THOSE ISSUES WILL BE
DEBATED- THIS BILL THIS BILL IS
MORE ABOUT- IN THOSE AREAS THAT
ALREADY ARE BILLS. AND WHERE
NEW DEVELOPMENTS TO OCCUR THAT
WE MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST QUALITY BUILDING
STANDARDS THAT WE MAKE SURE WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE
STANDARDS WHEN IT COMES TO
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROTECTION AND
WE HAVE ADEQUATE PROGRAMMING TO
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO
COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE THE KIND
OF CIVIC AND BUILD
INFRASTRUCTURE NOT TO MENTION
THE NATURE BASED INFRASTRUCTURE
WE NEED TO GET THROUGH- THIS
WILDFIRE YOUR. THAT IS IT IS
JUST BEGUN. I THE PROGRAM. THAT
WE WORKED OUT- IN THIS BILL
WOULD. ADDRESS MUCH NEEDED
FUNDING IN AREAS OF DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTION. AREA HOME
HARDENING. YOU KNOW WE TOOK
EARLY ACTION THIS YEAR IN OUR
BUDGET AND THERE WAS SOME
REALLY EXCITING WORK THAT
HAPPENED BUT TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF HOW DAUNTING THE
PROBLEM IT. THE ENTIRE
HARDENING BUDGET THAT WE JUST
AUTHORIZED THE GOVERNOR TO
SIGN. WILL TACKLE ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND HOMES OUT THERE THE
DESPERATELY NEED DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTIONS. THERE ARE
MORE HOMES THAT NEED THOSE SAID
I'D SAY MORE. A LOT OF THIS IS
ON PRIVATE HOMEOWNERS TO DO
THAT WORK. A LOT OF IT
SHOULDN'T NECESSARILY BE FUNDED
BY GOVERNMENT- BUT WE NEED A
FRAMEWORK AND WE NEED STANDARDS
TO GET THAT WORK DONE SO I'M
HOPING WE CAN GET THIS BILL
DONE THIS SESSION AND USE THIS
INCREDIBLE COALITION. TO FIND
SOME DURABLE CHANGE IN THIS
AREA THAT I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE ON- THAT MEANS IN THE
COALITION HERE'S THE FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION THE NATIONAL
FIRE PROTECTION ASSOCIATION THE
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
CHAPARRAL INSTITUTE AND
NUMEROUS ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS
AS WELL AS PG&E SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON- THIS BILL IS
NO OPPOSITION SO THANK YOU FOR
THE INTELLIGENCE OF THE LONG
OPENING I KNOW YOU HAVE A BUSY
HEARING. BUT THIS STUFF'S
IMPORTANT SO THANKS FOR TAKING
A MOMENT TO RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTERS STERN-
I BELIEVE WE HAVE TO THE
WITNESSES SILVIA FERRARI. FROM
THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION. AND RICK
HAS LAID FROM THE CHAPARRAL
INSTITUTE. ARE YOU EACH HAVE
TWO MINUTES IF ONE OF YOU GOES
OVER TWO MINUTES THAT WILL TAKE
AWAY TIME FROM THE OTHER SO
PLEASE BE MINDFUL- SO WILL THEM
MODERATOR- PLEASE CALL OUR
WITNESSES. THOSE LINES ARE OPEN
IN MAY BEGIN. WELL MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS STILL BE OVER HERE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
THREE I'VE ALSO BEEN SKED BY
THE CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
TO EXTEND THEIR STRONG SUPPORT
FOR THIS MEASURE AS WELL.
INCREDIBLY MORE IMPORTANT
MEASURE THAT WILL ENHANCE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
CALIFORNIA AND EXPAND THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL'S WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE BUILDING STANDARDS
BETTER KNOWN AS WILL BE
STANDARD- THE STANDARD HAVEA
PROVEN HISTORY OF SUCCESS WHEN
DEALING WITH WILDFIRES. IN THE
PARADISE FIRE HOMES THAT MET
THE WILL BE STANDARD HAD
DEFENSIBLE SPACE HAD A SURVIVAL
RATE THREE TO FOUR TIMES
GREATER THAN THOSE THAT DID NOT
WE ALREADY HAVE MAPS THE STATE
VERY HIGH FIRE SEVERITY ZONE.
THIS IMPORTANT BILL THAT TO CAL
FIRE HATE FOR COMPLETE MAPS FOR
MODERATE AND. HIGH FIRE
SEVERITY ZONES. OPERATE
AGENCIES DOT BUILDING SPEAKS
THE APPLET. OF WHAT WE STAY. HI
FI SEVERITY DOLLARS AND THEN
CONSIDER WHETHER APPLE IS
DINNER B. EXPANDED TO INCLUDE
MODERATE FIRESTONE IS IN THE
STATE ELLERY REGION. CENTERS
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
BILL- THESE WILL BE STANDARD
HAVE SHOWN THAT THEY CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL VERY MUCH ENCOURAGE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
HE THANK YOU MISTER FERRARI
WILL NOW GO TO RICK HAS LIKE.%
HI THIS IS A CENTERS- AND STAFF
THIS RECALL THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAPARRAL INSTITUTE.
WE SET OUT TO YOU- PRETTY
IMPORTANT LETTER LAST MONTH
ABOUT IMPROVE THE GOVERNOR'S.
QUALIFIER BUDGET AND A FOCUS ON
ONE ISSUE SPECIFICALLY AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES TOO.
AND THAT IS WE DON'T HAVE A
HOME IGNITION PROBLEM UNIQUE WE
HAVE A HOME IGNITION PROBLEM-
NOT A WILDFIRE CONTROL PROBLEM-
IN. LAST YEAR'S ALAMEDA FIRE UP
IN ASHLAND AND TALENT OREGON.
THEY SPEND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ON SENDING BACK COUNTRY COURSE.
STILL LOCKED TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED HOMES AND YOU DON'T
KNOW ABOUT PARADIS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WE LOST
ELEVEN THOUSAND HOMES OUT
THERE. AND THE FIRE HAD MOVED
THROUGH THIRTY THOUSAND ACRES
OF TEN YEAR OLD VEGETATION OR
HIT THE TOWN. AND SO THE THING
THAT'S REALLY IMPACTING THESE.
COMMUNITIES IT IS NOT.
NECESSARILY THE WILDLAND
VEGETATION OFTEN FAR AWAY FROM
THE COMMUNITIES AT RISK BUT BUT
THE NUMBERS. AND THE WIND
DRIVEN EMBERS OF THE THINGS
THAT- IMPACT ON THE MOST. AND
SO CLEARING HABITAT NOT REALLY
THE ANSWER- WHAT WE GOTTA DO IS
STOP PUTTING NEW NEIGHBORHOOD
IN HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS WHICH
THIS BILL THAN A DOZEN CARS
BUT- REPRESENT THE ONES THAT
ARE AND A LOT OF LITTLE THINGS
WE CAN DO- EMBER RESISTANT THAN
NON FLAMMABLE ROOFING- PROPER
DEFENSIBLE SPACE WHICH MEANS
YOU DON'T REMOVE EVERYTHING'S
IN THE DIRT YOU CREATE A- BIT
OF- BARRIER FOR AMHERST AT THE
HOUSE AND IT'S- ALL ABOUT THE
EMBERS. WHICH THIS BILL
MENTIONS MANY- AND SEX AND AT
THE HERE. ONE IDEA WE THROWN
AROUND A LOT OUT THE-
DISCUSSION ABOUT EXTERIOR
SPRINKLERS. SOMETIMES YOU'LL
HEAR REASONS WHY SUCH THINGS
WON'T WORK BUT- BUT I LIKE YOU
ALL TO ENCOURAGE IS SORT OF A-
NASA MOON LAUNCH APPROACH TO
THESE THINGS. GOOD FLKS AND
ROMAN AND THE AND THE CRITERIA
HERE IS. LET'S LET'S NOT
CRITICIZE IDEAS LET'S FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN MAKE IT WORK. SO
EXTERIOR SPRINKLERS ARE ONE
OPTION THAT THE CANADIANS AND
THEY ARE STRANDED USED WITH
GREAT SUCCESS SO. HOPEFULLY
THIS BILL. WILL BE PASSED AND
IT WILL. INITIATE. A LOT OF THE
ISSUES THAT COME. BUT I'M JUST
YEARS THANK YOU MUCH. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WE WILL
NOW GO TO ANY PUBLIC COMMENTS
IN THE SENATE CHAMBERS. SEEING
NINE- WE WILL GO TO ROOM. ONE
TWELVE I SEE NO ONE THERE- WILL
NOW GO TOWARDS OUR SUPPORTIVE
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE PHONE
LINES- AND FOR- OUR PUBLIC
COMMENTERS IN THE PHONE LINES
PLEASE YOUR- PUBLIC COMMENTS TO
BE LIMITED TO YOUR NAME YOUR
AFFILIATION IF ANY- AND THE
FACT THAT YOU SUPPORT.
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON
YOUR TELEPHONE AGAIN THAT'S ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD. WE'LL GO FIRST LINE
SIXTY SIX SIX SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING NATALIE BUT
BORROWED ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION BARS IN SUPPORT.
OF NEXT WE HAVE LINE EIGHTY TWO
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AREN'T ABLE AND FIT
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. WE HAVE LINE SIXTY
NINE SIX NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING SHARE NUMBERS
CAPTAIN BOARD FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT.
WE HAVE LINE FIFTY FIVE FIVE
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS- TO BEING
A PLUMBING WITH THE TO THE GAS
AND ELECTRIC COMPANY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO FOR THE
LINES IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL NOW
GO TO OPPOSITION WE HAVE NO
LEAD OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED FOR
SB SIXTY THREE. IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE CHAMBERS IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NINE- AND I DO NOT SEE
ANYONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- SO-
WILL THE MODERATOR PLEASE- SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES. THANK YOU
THE STATE OPPOSITION TO SB
SIXTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO PLEASE. THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU WE WILL NOW BRING IT BACK-
TO THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
RELATING TO SB. SIXTY THREE.
OKAY SEEING NINE DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. MOTION BY SENATOR
CORTEZ HE- AND CENTER STERN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THAT I
THINK YOU DID MENTION THE-
AMENDMENTS IN YOUR- OPENING BUT
I ALSO CAN YOU JUST CONFIRM
THAT YOU'RE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS. YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR GLAD TO
ACCEPT AND APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- THESE
WIND DRIVEN EMBERS DRIVEN FIRES
ARE WOULD. BURN MY PLACE DOWN
IN WOLSEY IN SO MANY THOUSANDS
OF OTHERS- I THINK WE CAN START
TO MAKE SOME BIG CHANGES WE GET
THIS BILL DONE SO. SINCERELY
APPRECIATE YOUR PUTTING YOUR
TIME AND EFFORT INTO THIS AND
HOUSING COMMITTEE RESPECTFULLY
ASK. THANK YOU SENATOR- I AM
RECOMMENDING AND I. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS- AND WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR STERN
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR WIENER
AYE WIENER I'D BATES. CABALLERO
HI COPYRIGHT CORTEZ HE- RETURNS
THE AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL A
BOOK HI FOR CHILDREN I SKINNER-
BURKE HI NUMBER WHAT KASKY.
FIVE FIVE OKAY THAT HAS ENOUGH
VOTES WILL PLACE AN ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SENATOR
EXCUSE ME SB FIVE SIXTY THREE
BY SENATOR ALAN- CENTER ALLEN
WELCOME AND YOU MAY PRESENTS
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
BECAUSE I LIKE TO THINK THE
CHAIR AND- HIS EXCELLENT STAFF
FOR THEIR- FOR. FOR WORKING
WITH MY OFFICE TO IMPROVE HIS
LEGISLATION I'M VERY HAPPY TO
ACCEPT AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED
IN. COMMENTS EIGHT AND NINE OF
THE ANALYSIS AND I WANNA-
PUBLICLY. COMMIT TO PARTNERING
WITH THE COMMITTEE TO IMPROVE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND DATA
COLLECTION FRAMEWORK IN THE
BILL. THAT IS AS DISGUSTING
COMMENT TEN. TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
THREE UPDATES AND IMPROVES UPON
THE SECOND NEIGHBORHOOD INFILL
FINANCING TRANSIT IMPROVEMENTS
ACTS NIFTY TO. A VOLUNTARY TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING TOOL TO
CATALYZE AFFORDABLE. INFILL
HOUSING NEAR TRANSIT AND CENTER
IF YOU COULD MAYBE ADJUST THE
MICROPHONE YOU'RE A LITTLE SOFT
NOW OKAY GREAT THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. SO SAW THIS COMMITTEE
NEWS IN THE WAKE OF
REDEVELOPMENT'S DISSOLUTION THE
LEGISLATURE HAS CREATED
NUMEROUS INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING INSTRUMENTS THAT HAVE
YET TO CATALYZES GRADUAL GROWTH.
FIFTY TWO WAS ESTABLISHED IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE HOUSING
AND TRANSIT ADVOCATES TO
PROVIDE CITIES AND COUNTIES.
WITH A FINANCING TOOL THAT
ESPECIALLY INCENTIVIZE THE
DEVELOPMENT AND CONSTRUCTION OF
HOUSING AND TRANSIT ORIENTED.
COMMUNITIES THE LEGISLATION
THAT I'M OFF THE TOP THIRD.
CREATING THE STATUE A FEW YEARS
BACK ALSO REQUIRE THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH OPR TO STUDY AND
REPORT ON THE EFFECTIVENESS. OF
TAX INCREMENT TOOLS FOR
INCREASING HOUSING PRODUCTION.
SO OPS REPORT RELEASED EARLIER
THIS YEAR. NOTES THAT LIMITED
REVENUE POTENTIAL OF
INCREMENTAL OF INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOLS. QUOTE
SIGNIFICANT LIMITS THEIR
ABILITY TO ASSIST IN MEETING
STATE HOUSING GOALS AND CELL
FATE AND RECOMMENDED. AN
EXPLORATION OF WAYS TO
POTENTIALLY LEVERAGE EXISTING
STATE PROGRAMS AND FUNDING
SOURCES TO ENABLE THE USEOF
FINANCING. NOT TO PROMOTE
LOCATION EFFICIENT DEVELOPMENT
AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN
PLACES WHERE CURRENT INCREMENTS
FINANCING TOOLS ALONE MAY BE
INSUFFICIENT. SO THIS BILL IS
INCORPORATED- PR'S
RECOMMENDATION ENVISIONING A
ROLE FOR POTENTIAL STATE
FUNDING TO BOLSTER SHOULD CALL
WITH CITIES AND COUNTIES A
BUILDING INFILL HOUSING
COMPLEMENTARY THE FIRST OPTION
YOUR TRANSIT. IT ALSO
STRENGTHENS NIFTY TEARS TENANT
PROTECTIONS HOMELESSNESS
PREVENTION INTO DISPLACEMENT
PROVISIONS. ENSURING THAT
DISTRICTS AUGMENT BUT NOT
UNINTENTIONALLY UNDERMINE
CALIFORNIA'S AFFORDABLE HOUSING
STOCK. SO THE IDEA IS THAT BY
ESTABLISHING A ROBUST FRAMEWORK
FOR COLLABORATION AND CO
INVESTMENT BETWEEN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ITS COUNTIES AND
CITIES WHO WISH TO WILL WORK
TOGETHER TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING TO PREVENT
HOMELESSNESS. IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL SB FIFTY
SIX FIVE SIXTY THREE PROVIDES A
MECHANISM THAT CAN MARSHAL MORE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES THAN ANYONE
LEVEL GOVERNMENT. I CAN PROVIDE
A LOAN SO ON THE PHONE WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE BEEN USING WHO IS
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF MY VALLEY
AND SENATE CONSERVATIVES RIGHTS
A CO SPONSORS. OF THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK HI THERE CAN
YOU CAN I CAN ARRANGE WE WILL
NOW GO TO. ORDERS THAT SUPPORTS
HER ANYTHING- MISTER ZANE YOU
MAY PROCEED AND YES WE CAN HEAR
YOU. THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
THAT YOUR PERSON WINTER VICE
CHAIR BATES. AND MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE HOUSING COMMITTEE AND
THEN THE SAME I'M EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE VALET AND I'M
ALSO A CO CHAIR OF SANTA
MONICA'S FOR RENTER'S RIGHTS-
LEWIS PLEASE JOIN SANTA MONICA
SYRINGES RIGHTS A CO SPONSOR
FIVE FIFTY FIVE SIX THREE AND
THANK. OUR AUTHORS ENTER ALLEN
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP EFFORTS HERE
WE WANT TO ENCOURAGE THE
SUPPORT OF MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
CALIFORNIA'S PAR EXCEEDS THE
RESOURCES. THAT CAN BE
REASONABLY EXPECTED FROM ANY
ONE LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT.
DEVELOPING SUFFICIENT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN MEETING
THIS CHALLENGE AND THE
CHALLENGE OF HOMELESSNESS WILL
REQUIRE THAT CITIES COUNTIES
AND STATES WORK TOGETHER IN
PARTNERSHIP. AND FOR EACH TO
BRING RESOURCES TO THE TABLE.
SB FIVE SIX THREE CREATES A
FRAMEWORK FOR PARTNERSHIP
COLLABORATION CONVALESCENT
BETWEEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
IT'S COUNTIES AND CITIES WHEN
THEY WISH TO WORK TOGETHER TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND TO
PREVENT PREVENT HOMELESSNESS.
SB FIVE SIXTY THREE ENABLES THE
CITY AND COUNTY THE CONTINENT
RAIMENT DEFORMING NEXT TO TWO
TAX INCREMENT DISTRICT NEAR
TRANSIT. WHICH CAN BEST
PROPERTY TAX INCREMENT IN THE
DISTRICT SO LONG AS 40% OF THE
TOTAL RESOURCES ARE INVESTED IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. FOR
HOMELESS PREVENTION. THEY CITY
AND MAKES A GREAT. SB FIVE
THREE. OF THE STATE. OF
CALIFORNIA WILL PUT. FUNDS TO
MATCH HOW OF THE FUNDS OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY- COMBINED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING RESOURCES
BUT ONLY. IF THE LEGISLATURE
HAS ALREADY APPROPRIATED FUNDS
FOR THIS PURPOSE AND WITHIN THE
LIMITS OF WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED. WE ARE PLEASED TO
ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT SUGGESTED
BY THE CHAIR. AND LOCATES
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPMENT OF
PROGRAM GUIDELINES AND
IMPLEMENTATION AT H. C. D. SB
FIVE SIX THREE. FIVE SIX THREE
RESPECTS THE ORIGINAL THAT THE
TWO LEGISLATIONS COMMITMENT.
SUCH DISTRICTS TO FUND PROJECTS
IN NEAR PROXIMITY TO TRANSIT
SERVICE IN ORDER THAT THE
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. BUT SHE'S DEVELOPING
REDUCTIONS ON THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS WHICH HAVE
BECOME AN IMPORTANT PART OF
STATE POLICY- IT ALSO RESPECTS
THE TEAM'S CURRENT COMMITMENT
THAT 10% OF TOTAL RESOURCES-
BUDGET SHOULD BE INVESTED IN
URBAN GREENING AND FIRST LAST
MILE. PEDESTRIAN AND BICYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE TO HELP CREATE
ATTRACTED BURDENS.
NEIGHBORHOODS WITH EASY ACCESS
TO TRANSIT. THESE OBJECTIVES
ARE ALL CONSISTENT WITH STATE
OF CALIFORNIA OBJECTORS
REFLECTED IN THE POLICIES GUIDE
IN THE USE OF GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FONG. SB FIVE SIXTY
THREE ALSO INCORPORATES A
COMMITMENT TO SKILLED AND
TRAINED LABOR POLICIES. WE
REGARD SUCH COMMITMENT NOT AS A
BURDEN BUT AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REFLECT CALIFORNIA'S COMMITMENT
TO JUST LABOR POLICIES. AND TO
BRING THE FAMILY OF LABOR INTO
THE COALITION CHAMPION IN
ROBUST RESOURCES FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE VERY MUCH IN THE
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR. FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP AND SERVICE TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER JAMES- WILL
NOW GO TO THE SENATE- CHAMBERS
IS THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT HE
WAS LAYING. WALKING UP. GOOD
GOOD MORNING ERIN MY NAME. ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
THERE HALF A MILLION MEMBERS IN
SUPPORT OF SB FIVE SIX STRAIGHT
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT IN THE SENATE
CHAMBERS- SAYING NINE- I SEE NO
ONE IN ROOM ONE TWELVE- AND WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES.
THS IS SUPPORT- FOR SB FIVE
SIXTY THREE AGAIN PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME FILIATION IF ANY AND
THE FACT OF YOUR SUPPORT. STATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL ON
THE PHONE LINES ME PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
KEYPAD AGAIN THAT'S A ONE
FOLLOWED BY ISRAEL PLEASE. WE
WILL GO FIRST TO THE LINE OF
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
BUSINESS KILEY JOAQUIN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
pWORKERS CALIFORNIA STATE PIPE
TRADES COUNCIL AND WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS WORKING OR SUPPORT FOR
SENATE BILL FIVE SIX THREE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE NINETY FIVE NINE FIVE
OR ONE OF THE ISSUES. HELLO MY
NAME IS MICHAEL CHARLTON IN SAN
FRANCISCO- NO WE NO INVALID AND
I SUPPORT S. C. A. TO. VERY
MUCH. NO LONGER LINE EIGHTY
EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ALFRED BERKELEY
CALIFORNIA A. B. AT THIS TIME
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OKAY WILL
NOW GO TO OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE
SIXTY THREE OUR LEAD OPPOSITION
IS MARK STIVERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
WHO IS IN THE GALLERY MR
STIVERS YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK
YOU MARCH DIVERSE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
FOR SAID LIKE SAY WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
TO GROW RESOURCES FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS- WE CONSIDER THE
AUTHOR TO CHAMPION FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL CAN
EFFECTIVELY CONTAINS A UNION
ONLY CONSTRUCTION REQUIREMENT.
THAT THE RENDERS THE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING RELATIVELY USELESS.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER
SEE A BENEFIT EMPLOYEE UNION
MEMBERS BUT THIS ABSOLUTE
REQUIREMENT IGNORE THE
REALITIES OF THE WORKPLACE. OF
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPER COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW
HAS A LOOK ST DIFFICULTY
GETTING THREE BIDS FOR ANY JOB
WITH THE PREVAILING WAGE
REQUIREMENT. AND THAT'S WHEN
AND BOTH UNION AND NONUNION
CONTRACTORS OR APPLYING ARE
BIDDING. THIS IS THIS- A
DIFFICULT IS PARTICULARLY
PRONOUNCED IN INLAND AREAS
WHERE WE ARE LIKELY TO GET.
WHERE I'M LIKE WE'RE LIKELY TO
BITS ONLY- WE ARE NOT LIKELY TO
GET BIDS FROM ANY UNION
CONTRACTORS AT ALL. THIS BILL
THIS BILL DISQUALIFIES HALF THE
WORK FORCE IN WHICH CASE THE
DEVELOPERS WILL BE UNABLE TO
GET ANY BIDS OR BE SUBJECT TO
THE MARKET POWER OF A SINGLE
BIDDER. IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE BUILDING TRADES
RELEASED A REPORT STATED AMONG
OTHER THINGS CALIFORNIA NEEDS
TO DOUBLE OR TRIPLE ITS
WORKFORCE EMPLOYED IN NEW
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION. AND%
EXPANDING A PRODUCTIVE
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION WORK
FORCE AS RAPIDLY AS REQUIRED%
WILL BE A SPECIALLY CHALLENGING
DUE TO COMPETITION FROM NON
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS. AS A RESULT THE
UNION ONLY LANGUAGE WILL RENDER
THE BILL RELATIVELY USELESS IN
MOST PARTS OF THE STATE. AND
MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE THAN OTHER
PARTS UNTIL WE CAN GROW THAT
WORK FORCE WHICH WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
TRADES ON. AFFORDABLE HOUSING
COMMUNITY HAS OFFERED
AMENDMENTS THAT WILL PRIORITIZE
AND GROWN UNION LABOR WHILE
ALSO PUTTING RESPONSIBLE
GUARDRAILS IN PLACE TO ENSURE
THAT FOUR WHEEL HOUSING CAN
MOVE FORWARD AT A REASONABLE
COST. WE UNFORTUNATELY MUST
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED THE
BILL'S AMENDED TO INCLUDE THESE
REASONABLE GUARDRAILS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE NOW GO. ANY PHONE OR
I'M SORRY ANY ADDITIONAL
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. SAYING NINE- WILL GO
TO ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO ONE
ROOM ONE TWELVE WHEN I GO TO
THE PHONE LINES- MODERATOR G.
PLEASE CALL FOR OPPOSITION- TO
SB FIVE SIXTY THREE AGAIN NAME
AFFILIATION IF ANY- AND THE
FACT OF YOUR OPPOSITION. THE
STATE YOUR OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO PLEASE.
WE DO HAVE A LINE MISTER
TERAPEUTA MOMENT BEFORE PROVIDE
BILLING NUMBER THANK YOU. OUR
COMMON CONCERN LINE NINETY FOUR
NINE FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD MORNING MELISSA HI TO I'M
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ALSO WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINE COMPUTER AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL
THEY'LL BRING THE BILL BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON SB. FIVE SIXTY THREE. CENTER
BATES. CLICK SENATOR ALLEN JUST
A CLARIFICATION ON THE ROLE OF
THE PUBLIC AND- THE DOG IF
THERE WAS OF THE PREVIOUS
VERSION ALLOW THE PUBLIC TO
HAVE. A STATEMENT OF OPPOSITION
OR AT LEAST HAVE SOME SORT OF
INPUT ON IT- IS IT RATHER THAN
A VOTE IS THAT STILL PART OF
THE BILL OR NOT I'M HAVING
TROUBLE FINDING AN ANSWER TO
THAT IN MY ANALYSIS. THIS IS
THE ISSUE THAT THE REALTORS WAS
RAISING WERE RAISING WITH
REGARDS TO- PROTEST PROVISIONS
IN THE CURRENT STATUS OF THE
PROJECT YEAH OKAY SO ON WE DID
REINSTATE SO- THE ORIGINAL
PROPOSAL DID ELIMINATE CERTAIN
PROTEST PROVISIONS WE HEARD
SOME CONSIDERABLE PUSHBACK
FROM- FROM THE REALTORS AND SO
WE REINSTATED THE LANGUAGE WITH
A FEW TWEAKS- I'M HOPEFUL THAT
WE'RE NOW. I'M VERY CLOSE TO
GETTING THEM TO REMOVE THEIR-
THEIR CONCERNS AND- SO WHAT
WERE IN THAT. CONVERSATION BUT
I THINK WE'VE I THINK WE
SUBSTANTIALLY MET. THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE PROTESTS PROVISIONS.
I DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE ON THE
PHONE OR ANYTHING BUT IF THEY
HAVE A CHANCE TO REVIEW OUR-
AMENDS. THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN
ARTICLE TODAY WILL BE ABLE TO
SUPPORT IT BUT I HI MOM I THINK
YOU'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION HERE I'M JUST GOING
TO HAVE TO OPPOSE TODAY UNTIL I
GET THAT CLARIFICATION. IT'S ON
CERTAINLY VERY BIG ISSUE YEAH
MY DISTRICT BECAUSE OF A LOT OF
THE- HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS AND
SOME OF THE HOUSING BILLS SO.
ANYWAY GOOD WORK ON IT SO FAR
THANKS OKAY YEAH I'M IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WE HAVE
RESOLVE THOSE CONCERNS- SO
MAYBE EVEN. BY THE END OF THE
HEARING WE DIDN'T GET YOUR
ISSUES RESOLVED AND MAYBE EARN
ABOUT YEAH- SETTLEMENTS ARE
AFTER AND- YOU CAN GET CLEARED.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. OKAY
SEEING NINE- THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE AND FOR TAKING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS-
PARTICULARLY THE ONE THAT
ENSURES THAT- CITIES THAT ARE
ACCESSING THESE FUNDS- DON'T
HAVE POLICIES DESIGNED TO
PROVIDE HOUSING. FROM BEING
BUILT WE ARE- IT'S AN IMPORTANT
PROVISION I APPRECIATE YOU
WORKING WITH US AND NOT ON SO
I'M RECOMMENDING AND I VOTE FOR
THE BILL AS AMENDED. I DO HAVE
A MOTION. MOTION BY SENATOR
CORTEZ EIGHT. MONTHS OLD AND
I'M SORRY CENTER YOU MAY CLOSE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COLLABORATION WITH THE CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE AND- SENATE BATES
WE WILL WE'LL GET WE'LL WE'LL
WE'LL GET ALL THAT INFORMATION
CLARIFIED NINE I THINK I THINK
YOU'LL FIND THAT TIME WE'VE
ADDRESSED THE- THE PROTEST
CONCERNS- SO WITH THAT I
RESPECT FASTER AND ABOUT. GREAT
MADAM CONSULTANT YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL
FIVE SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR
ALAN THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
AS AMENDED THE FIRST AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
WIENER AYE WIENER AYE BATES.
CABALLERO I CABALLERO HI
CORTICES HI COURTESY I MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL A BOOK NO ACTUALLY
BURKE KNOWS INNER. NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER FIVE WITH CASKEY. FOR
THE ONE OKAY WE'LL PUT THAT
BILL ON CALL FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTRO AND
WE'RE NEXT GOING TO GO TO ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT- BY CENTER BACKER WHO IS-
HERE WITH US SO SENATOR- YOU
MAY COME UP IN PRESENTS. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS. TO
CONTINUE THE EFFORT TO ADDRESS
THE STATE'S HOUSING SHORTAGE SB
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT WITH
STREAMLINED MIXED USE
COMMERCIAL SPACE CONVERSION
INTO EIGHTY YEARS. SPECIFICALLY
SEVEN SEVEN ACRE PRIVATE OWNERS
OF MIXED USE FOR MULTI FAMILY
BUILDINGS BITTERN UNUSED
COMMERCIAL SPACES IN THE EIGHTY
YEARS. AT A VALUABLE FORM OF
HOUSING AT BELOW MARKET PRICES
WITHIN EXISTING NEIGHBOURHOODS.
YOUR GUIDANCE ON OWNERS RIGHT
TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
RESIDENTIAL LIVING SPACES IN
THESE BUILDINGS IS VITAL TO
FILL IN CALIFORNIA STATED GOAL
TO INCREASE HOUSING SUPPLY.
WELL EXCEPT THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF PAGE FOR THE HOUSES
TO REINSTATE A CLAUSE THAT WAS
INADVERTENTLY DELETED. THIS
BILL HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND HAS NO
KNOWN KNOWN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME. BECAUSE OUR EXPECT WE ASK
HER AYE VOTE SB SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT. PROTESTS FRANCE PORT IS
TWENTY BILLION WITH A
CALIFORNIA PARTICIPATION. IN A
BUSINESSMAN MONTY WITH
CALIFORNIA BE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILL NOW GO TO MISTER
BREWERY AND RESTAURANT TAX YEAH
EACH OF YOU HAS TWO MINUTES- SO
MISTER BREWERY IF YOU'RE GONNA
BURST- IF YOU GO OVER TWO
MINUTES YOU'LL BE TAKING TIME
FROM HIS TORONTOAND I KNOW YOU
WOULD NOT WANT TO DO THAT SO-
PLEASE BE MINDFUL AND- WE'RE
GOOD EARLY WITNESSES. OKAY I'LL
BE BRIEF- OF TWENTY WILL BE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION. CENTER BAKER
STATED. SB SEVENTY SOMETHING
CLARIFIED WITH THE SMALL
AUTHORIZED THE- STREAMLINED
APPROVAL EIGHTY YOU
CONSTRUCTION. OF BEIJING AND
UNUSED COMMERCIAL RETAIL SPACE.
THAT WE ALL HAVE SEEN IN THE
NEWS HELP COMPLETING. HOUSING
CRISIS CAUSED BY A LACK OF. YOU
HELPING STRUCTURE AT ALL LEVELS.
HOW THE PRODUCTION ACTUALLY
FROM ACROSS THE- SEVEN SEVEN
BIG WITH PROVIDED A OPTION TO
PURCHASE EIGHTY CONSTRUCT HELP
WITH STATE HEALTH. WHAT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WE ARE LOCAL
COMPOUND THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH RESTAURANTEUR. HI
GOOD MORNING IT'S CHAIR MEMBERS
WAS MONTANA CALIFORNIAN BEACH
HERE TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT SB SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
I THINK THAT ARE BACKGROUND
DATA VERY ABLE JOB DESCRIBED
THE BILL IN THE COMPARTEN SO
I'LL JUST ADD THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE IS ONE WEEK HERE UP AND
DOWN CALIFORNIA INCLUDING
COMPLAINING ABOUT PROVIDING
CLARITY ON THE PART OF EIGHTY
YOU ARE WILL HELP SETTLE
DISAGREEMENTS ARISING FROM THE
AMBIGUITY. AND VERY IMPORTANT
YOU CLEAR WAY. I DO KNOW HOW.
FACE REALLY CRUSHING HOW CRISIS
ONE BORN ABOUT THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOME SHORTAGE. SB SEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT HELP CALIFORNIANS
STRUGGLING UNDER THAT HOUSING
PRICES BY CLARIFYING THE LAW.
ALLOWING THE CONVERSION OF
UNUSED RETAIL SPACE INTO MULTI
IN MULTI FAMILY BUILDING IANS-
FORTUNATELY MANY OF THESE
RESULT THEY HAVE GONE FOR
BECAUSE THAT BECAUSE A PANDEMIC.
IN THE STRUGGLE THAT MANY
BUSINESSES MADDEN THING AFLOAT.
I'M NOT KEEPING ITS RETAIL
SPACES THEY CAN GET NOW
POLLUTION TO THEIR PROBLEMS I
THINK THAT THE SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT RIGHT THEY BURY MY
BALANCE ALLOWING THE NEWS
RESULT. IN BURKE AT AND T'S I
WHICH ARE TRADITIONALLY MUCH
CHEAPER. THAN COMMENSURATE. I
WOULD THAT I WOULD THANK THEM
BACKER IN THE PORT ISSUE TO THE
OR AND I. YOU TO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RESTAURANTS THERE
WILL NOW GO TO- SUPPORT OF
PUBLIC CON. FOR ANYONE IN THE
SENATE CHAMBERS. I SAY NINE.
WILL TO ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE
NO ONE ROOM ONE TWELVE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR TEAM PLEASE QUEUE UP
SUPPORT. FOR SB SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU TO STATE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AGAIN
USING YOUR TELEPHONE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO WE WILL GO
ORDER LINE NUMBER NINETY ONE
NINE ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SILVIO FERRARI
ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT. WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
LINES AS WELL ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NEXT HEADLINE. HELLO THIS IS
MICHAEL BACKGROUND FROM CASTRO
VALLEY AND THE CALLING AT THE
PORT AT THE SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE A THIRD LINE
IN Q. AS LINE NUMBER. EIGHTY
NINE EIGHT NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS TAKING
CALLING FROM UNION FIFTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. WE DO HAVE
A FOURTH AND FINAL LINING CUTE
OR WITH AN OPERATOR ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. PINE TWELVE ONE TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI I WOULD
REALLY JUST I WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO- SAY TO MR BARANGAY THERE IS
NO NEED FOR THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION HOMES EVEN THE STATE'S
FINANCIAL BOARD OF FINANCE
BOARD HAS ACKNOWLEDGED THAT
THAT IS A REALLY EXAGGERATED
NUMBER PLEASE STOP USING IT IN
THE SHOULD NOT BE USING THAT
INFORMATION TO CHINA THAT SELLS
FOR. PUBLIC COMMENTS. NOT FOR
OPPOSITION. THERE ARE NO OTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WE WILL NOW GO TO OPPOSITION WE
HAVE NO- LEAD OPPONENT
IDENTIFIED. IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE SENATE
GALLERY SAYING I'M- GOING TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE I SEE NO ONE
THERE WHEN I GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR PEOPLE WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT. THE STATE
YOUR POSITION OF OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE ZERO
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN
Q. WILL BE JUST A MOMENT. WE
WILL GO TO THAT LINE NOW MY
NUMBER TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN TO DISCOVER HER. HI MY
NAME'S ALISON TRIED CALLING UP
A LOT BETTER I AM. FINE I
ACTUALLY AM CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT.
BROUGH ONLINE THE APPROPRIATE
ROUND AND PUSH IT THANKS. AND
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
REEBOK THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON SB SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHTS. OKAY- SEEING. NINE
CENTER BACK ON THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING US FOR IT EVEN THOUGH
IT IS SORT OF IT LOOKS LIKE- SO
SMALL TECHNICAL ABILITY IT'S
ACTUALLY QUITE IMPACTFUL BY
MAKING CLEAR. THAT YOU KNOW THE
YEARS OF SERVICE TERRIER TYPE
THAT HE TO USE ARE ONLY ABOUT A
SINGLE FAMILY OME IN
CONVERTING A GARAGE OR YARD
COTTAGE UP EIGHTY YEARS ALSO
HAVE A ROLE TO PLAY IN MULTI
UNIT AND MIXED USE CETERA. I
SERVICES ARE REALLY- IMPORTANT
TACTICAL AND I APPRECIATE YOU
BRING FORWARD- AND I'M
RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE WELL
WITH THE AMENDMENTS. CENTER
CABALLERO. SENATE CAREER MOVES
A- CENTER YOU CLOSE. I
APPRECIATE THE YOUR COMMENTS
THE MEASURE AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
I'M NOT A CONSULTANCY- YOU MAY
CALL THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE
BILL SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR BACKER OF THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR WIENER HI. I BATES.
CABALLERO HI COPYRIGHT CORTEZ
HE COURTESY AYE MCGUIRE CHAU
BOOK I HAVE A JOB I SKINNER.
NUMBER FIVE NUMBER I WOOD
COUNTY. FIVE L. A. THAT HAS
ENOUGH PHOTO FOR ON CALL TO THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
SENATOR. OKAY WE WILL NOW GO TO
ITEM SEVEN SB SIX- CENTER
CABALLERO- WILL BE PRESENTING
FROM HER DESK. THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS- THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY PER PRESENT SB
SIX THE NEIGHBORHOOD HOMES ACT.
AS YOU RE ALL AWARE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO FACE AN EXTREME
HOUSING CRISIS IN ORDER TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIANS
FAMILY THE STATE MUST INCREASE
HOUSING PRODUCTION. YET THE
LACK OF AVAILABLE LAND FOR
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT
CONTINUES TO BE A BARRIER TO
BUILD. MANY OF OUR CITIES ARE
BUILT OUT AND DON'T HAVE.
AVAILABLE VACANT LAND IN OTHER
CITIES ARE RELUCTANT RELUCTANT
TO DEVELOP HOUSING ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF THEIR JURISDICTION
WHICH CONTRIBUTES TO URBAN
SPRAWL AND GREENHOUSE GASES. SB
SIX TAKES THE CONCEPT
ARTICULATED IN SB THREE SEVENTY
FIVE THIS IS BEING ABLE
COMMUNITY STRATEGY. TO REDUCE
THE TIME AND DISTANCE PEOPLE
TRAVEL BY VEHICLE AND THE REUSE
AND ADAPT. UNDERPERFORMING
PROPERTIES TO CREATE WALKABLE
COMMUNITIES AND AVOID SPRAWL
THIS ADAPTIVE REUSE BILL WILL
SPUR HOUSING PRODUCTION BY
AUTHORIZING RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS ON EXISTING LOTS
CURRENTLY ZONED FOR COMMERCIAL
OFFICE AND RETAIL USE. SUCH AS
STRIP MALLS. LARGE MALLS OR BIG
BOX RETAIL SPACES SB SIX WILL
ALSO SOLVE AND INVOLVING CRISIS
THAT HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS
DURING THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. WHICH IS WHICH HAS
SHIFTED BUSINESSES TO ACCEPT
SOME PERMANENTLY NEW WORK FROM
HOME STRATEGIES AND EXPANDED
ONLINE TRANSACTIONS FOR
CONSUMER RETAIL. NUMEROUS MAJOR
COMMERCIAL TENANTS HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY MAY BE
FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY RELIEF
ARE CLOSING STORES DUE TO THE
DECLINE IN SALES SALES AT
PHYSICAL STORE LOCATIONS SUCH
AS SEARS J. C. PENNEY'S KMART
AND TOYS R. US AND MANY OTHERS.
WE'VE SEEN THE SHIFT IN
CONSUMER PREFERENCE OVER TIME
WHICH HAS LEFT MANY COMMUNITIES
WITH STRIP MALLS AND MALLS WITH
MAJOR TENANT BACON SEES WHICH
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DECLINE OF
THE RETAIL CENTER INCREASING
BLIGHT. VANDALISM AND DECLINING
SALES REVENUES IN MY RURAL
DISTRICT THESE RETAILERS ARE
OUR MAJOR TENANTS AND I EXPECT
TO SEE MANY MORE LEAVES AS THE
ECONOMY CONTINUES TO STRUGGLE.
MANY CORPORATE ENTERPRISES ARE
FOR GOING THEIR BRICK AND
MORTAR OPERATIONS IN FAVOR OF A
NEW WORK FROM HOME REALITY.
TECH GIANTS SUCH AS FACEBOOK
HAVE EMBRACED A PERMANENT WORK
FROM HOME STRATEGY LEAVING
BEHIND MASSIVE COMMERCIAL
CENTERS WITH UNCERTAIN FUTURES.
THESE UNDER UTILIZED FOR VACANT
COMMERCIAL SPACES ARE ALONG
MAJOR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
ROUTES AND CONTAINS SIX
SIGNIFICANT ACREAGE AVAILABLE
TO BE DEVELOPED FOR MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE A
WALKABLE LIVE WORK PLAY
VILLAGE. THE WALKABLE VILLAGE
CON CON SUPPORT WILL ALSO HELP
TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BY CREATING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLE MILES
TRAVELED- TWO ERRANDS. WITHIN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITY WHICH CAN
BE ACCESSED THROUGH WALKING
MOST SIMPLY SB SIX WILL SPUR
HOUSING PRODUCTION BY ALLOWING
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. TO
APPROVE RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED
USE DEVELOP ON COMMERCIAL ZONED
RETAILER SPACES. BY UTILIZING
AN EXPEDITED PROCESS REQUIRE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT MEET OR
EXCEED THE DENSITY DEEMED
APPROPRIATE TO ACCOMMODATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUCH AS
APARTMENTS TOWN HOMES AND
CONDOMINIUMS. AND PROVIDE
FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL DECISION
MAKING BY SUBJECTING
DEVELOPMENT TO LOCAL PLANNING
PARKING AND DESIGN. ORDINANCES
WITH NO COST TO THE STATE SB
SIX WILL INCENTIVIZE
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENTS
WITHOUT IMPACTING SINGLE FAMILY
NEIGHBORHOODS BY GIVING
LANDOWNERS AND DEVELOPERS AWAY
TO MEET THE GROWING DEMAND FOR
HOUSING THIS BILL WILL ALSO
SPUR ECONOMIC ACTIVITY A
CRITICAL COMPONENT TO ECONOMIC
RECOVERY. DURING THIS PAN
SESSION TO QUOTE THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM BERKELEY IN
REGION'S MOST NEED IN NEED OF
REVITALIZATION AND IS A STEP
FORWARD TOWARDS ECONOMIC
TRANSFERRED TRANSFORMATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THAT WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT
AND TO FACILITATE THE
DISCUSSION IS MELANIE BRADY
MONTEREY COUNTY HOUSING
INSPECTION PROGRAM SERVICES
MANAGER AND JENNIFER SPECHT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- CENTER GUERRERO WILL NOW
GO TO REALLY WIN THIS IS
MELANIE MORETTI ENGINE SPEC-
YOU WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH
AND AGAIN- IT'S FOUR MINUTES
TOTAL SO- PLEASE BE MINDFUL OF
NOT EATING INTO THE SECOND
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES- MISTER.
MODERATOR CAN PLEASE ARE CALLED
ME WITNESSES. THANK YOU IN
THOSE LINES ARE OPEN. OKAY DOES
BRADY. GOOD MORNING. GOOD
MORNING SHARE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS MELANIE PER ATTY AND I AM A
HOUSING SPECIAL PROGRAMS
SERVICES MANAGER FOR THE COUNTY
MODERATE. CAN YOU THINK PART AT
THE STATE. CAPITOL ERA. RIGHT
PRESIDENT ABOUT IT I CERTAINLY
FOUND OFFICE AND RETAIL. SB SIX
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THE PURCHASE
OF HOUSING DEVELOPMENT IT ADDS
WHAT WHAT THE- LOCALLY
ADDITIONAL PORTABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IS A HUGE PRIORITY.
THE COVERED NINETEEN CAL POLY
FASCINATED THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS. SB SIX WOULD CREATE
OPPORTUNITY TO LEAD THE COUNTY
FLEXIBILITY TO BUILD MORE
QUICKLY NEEDED HOUSING MARKET
RATE AND AFFORDABLE UNIT. WHAT
MAKES IT INTO THE BALLOT. IN
WILL COUNTY EFFECTIVE MODERATE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS TO
SUPPORT HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
CREATE A COSTLY BARRIER THAT
CAN RENDER AN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECT IN PEOPLE.
THIRTY TWO THAT HAVE BEEN ON
SITE THAT ALREADY HAVE OR-
EXISTING WATER AND SEWER
SERVICES REDUCES THE NEED FOR
HIGH HOP INFRASTRUCTURE. THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT OF LIKE OUR
MEAL BURKE BUT IT NEVER BROKEN
WATER. IT HAPPENED XIN. SO NOT
ONLY THE THIRD LARGEST CITY
AND- KMART OR WEST OF HIGHWAY
ONE AND HERE'S AN EASY ONE ONE.
REPLY SADNESS. YES THEY ARE
OFFERED WITH THE- DEVELOPMENT
AND REVITALIZATION IT AND THEIR
PROXIMITY TO SHOPS AND- PRESS
THE CANYON AND THEN. OPEN A
CLEAN OKAY BACON'S FOR OFFICE.
LAST RAMP COOPER JUNE. THE FOR
THE RED OF ABOUT. FOR
COMMERCIAL CENTERS THAT THEY
NEED TO THRIVE YET HAVE YOU ARE
UNDER UTILIZED PARKING LOT THE
KING I CAN EASILY ENVISION A
PROPERLY DESIGNED MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT TOP OF JOBS IN. THE
FACE OF BLOCK OF. FOR THESE
REASONS AND ARE COUNTY MODERATE
PERSPECTIVE AND ANNA CABALLERO
AND IT. VOTERS. FOR I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH OF BEFORE GO TO MISS
US I USED ON A MAKE FAIR FOR
ANYONE WHO MIGHT BE AND ALSO
FOR AUTHORS- FOR YOUR LEAD
WITNESS SAYS- I THINK IT'S- AND
WE STARTED TO DO THIS WE SHOULD
ADVISE PEOPLE. IF THEY HAVE A
LAND LINE THEY CAN CALL IN FROM
THAT IS IDEAL IN TERMS OF BEING
HEARD- AND IN ADDITION IF YOU
ARE ON A CELL PHONE- PLEASE
MAKE SURE TO HOLD IT IN A WAY.
RAY OF THE MOST CURABLE IF
THAT'S A WORD AND MAKE SURE
THAT YOU ARE IN A GOOD
RECEPTION AREA- IS PRETTY WE
COULD HEAR YOU BUT IT WAS JUST
A LITTLE ROUGH AND- AND DON'T
WORRY OTHERS HAVE BEEN IN THIS
POSITION SO WE STARTED TO.
ADVISOR LEAD WITNESSES TO
REALLY BE MINDFUL OF THAT SO I
JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT THERE
FOR WHOEVER MIGHT BE LISTENING
AT THE MOMENT- THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- NEXT WILL GO TO- MISS
MARK. SHARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER
SPECTROSCOPIC CALIFORNIA IS NOT
BUILT. FOR BOB AS BIG. SB SIX
ENCOURAGES THE DEVELOPMENT OF
MAKE INCOME DEVELOPMENT ON
UNDER UTILIZED PROPERTIES MOST
IMPORTANTLY SB SIX URGES THE
CONSTRUCTION OF NATURALLY
OCCURRING AFFORDABLE OWNER
OCCUPIED MARKET RATE HOUSING
WITH THE HELP BURKE BIRTHDATES
LOCKED OUT ACCORDING TO THE
FEDERAL RESERVE'S TWENTY
NINETEEN SURVEY OF MORE
FINANCES FAMILIAR WELCOMING
BERMAN ALMOST ENTIRELY. BY
HOMEOWNERSHIP STATUS. THE FACT
THE ABILITY TO ACT WITH ON
ABOUT OF THE WHILE ONLY
INVESTING A FRACTION OF THE
MONEY UP FRONT RIGHT THE ONLY
SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY FOR
WEALTH ACCUMULATION IN
CALIFORNIA. AS A RESULT WHILE
MEDIAN FAMILY IN THE U. S. HAD
A HUNDRED TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
AND REAL ESTATE REAL WEALTH IN
TWENTY NINETEEN. RENTER
FAMILIES HAVE ROUGHLY ONLY
SIXTY THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS AND
THAT WORK. BUT THEY HAVE HAD
FOR THE PAST FOUR DECADES. WHAT
A MEDIAN HOMEOWNER HAS ACQUIRED
AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH.
HELLO REYES AND TYPE LIKE
CONTINUE TO SEARCH UP HOME
PRICES YEAR OVER YEAR. THE THEY
WANT ME TO HOME PRICES OUT
TWENTY TWENTY WHAT ARE AT A
RECORD SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PRICE WOULD NOT BE A DECLINE AS
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF HOMES SO
ABOUT ACTING RIGHT AND WE AGAIN
SET A RECORD FOR THE MEDIAN
HOME PRICE NOW THAT'S A
STAGGERING SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
MARCH. EIGHT POINT 6% FROM
FEBRUARY IN TWENTY ALMOST. 24%
FROM MARCH TWENTY TWENTY.
FURTHERMORE ACCORDING FAIR TOLD
REPORTERS. INDEX GOING TO BLAST.
ORDER. TO PURCHASE A HOME MEDIA
PRICED EGGS FAMILY HOME IN
CALIFORNIA TWENTY FOUR WITH MY
BIRDS COMPARED 238% THE WHITE
HOUSE BILL. REPORTER THE WAS
DELYLAH LACK NEXTEL. TWENTY
THREE EARNINGS MINIMUM INCOME
NEEDED FOR MEDIA PRICED HOME.
THE STATE OF THE HOUSING FOR
ONLY TO Y. OUR WEALTH OUT.
UNTIL WE STATE CONTINUING BY
THE VISION AND THE CONSTRUCTION
MORE MAKE INCOME EARNERS THE-
WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO ADD
ADDRESS FIRST IT THE WOKE UP.
POLICY RIGHT SIX VITAL FOREVER
TO CREATE. A HOMEOWNER RATE
CREATING LONGER WEALTH- PROJECT
OPERA- BIRTHDATE THE
UNDERSERVED- I NEEDED. PRETTY
THREE RIVERS BY WORK ARRIVAL
HONESTY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
STARK. OKAY NOW GO TO SOME. OF
COMMENT S. B. C. SO OFTEN SO
GALLERY- ST. ERIN MY HAIR ON
BEHALF OF THE HAPPEN MEMBER OF
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES. IN
INDIA SIX OF SPORTS CABALLERO
BUILT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN SENATE GALA
SEEING NINE. WILL GO TO ROOM
ONE TWELVE- SCENE NINE WILL GO
TO THE PHONE LINES- MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE. GIVE
UP SUPPORT OF PUBLIC TESTIMONY
FOR SB SIX- AND AGAIN THIS IS
LIMITED TO NAME AFFILIATION IF
ANY AND THE FACT OF YOUR
SUPPORT. STATE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL PRESS ONE OVER THERE
ALL. WE'LL GO FIRST IN LINE TO
SPEAK. TO FLORIDA ATLANTIC AT
REPRESENTING THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. SIX WE HAVE LINED. SIX
SIX. THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE ON TO LINE.
NINETY ONE NINE ONE- HELLO SIR
WILL BE HAPPY FACEBOOK IN THE
PORT. BLIND. ONE OH THREE ONE
ZERO THREE. FURTHER THIS GREAT
HONOR WITH. A BURGER KING ON
BEHALF HYDROELECTRIC AMERICA IN
ORDER TO BUILD. SIXTY SEVEN MY
BOOK. HOLLY FOR MANY THEY HAD A
PUBLIC AFFAIR. CALLING ON
BEHALF OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND
THE COUNCIL BEEN FILTERED INTO
PARTNERS AND A COPY TO
COALITION IN PART OF THE
BUILDING FOR WORKING WITH
CURSOR. BLINKED OUT THANK ON.
IT I THINK. THANK. NINE ONE
TWENTY. RT WRITTEN ON HAPPEN
BUT BUILDING SUPPORT THANK YOU.
Y. AND. ONE OH SIX. HI WENDY
REYNOLDS CALIFORNIANS BY VOTERS
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL LOW IT'S
PART. WINONA A. BOB LOPEZ
ALAMEDA COUNTY DEMOCRATIC-
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF IN SUPPORT.
FIND. ONE TWENTY THREE. HI
DAVID KING T'CHALLA ON BEHALF
OF BETTER WAY CALIFORNIA AND ON
BEHALF OF THE AFFORDABLE HAPPEN
FASTER CALIFORNIA IMPORT. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED. SECURE MEMBERS
MIKE MONICA ME HALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE OF THE STATE
AND LOCAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
STATE BY PRETTY SKILLFUL
LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL EIGHTY
MEDEWERKERS. PART OF IT RESPECT
THANK. I AM TWENTY NINE. HI
THIS IS A CERTAIN LEVEL OF THE
LOS ANGELES BUSINESS COUNCIL ON
THE PART OF THAT ANYTHING THAT.
LINE. SIX HELLO THIS IS. OKAY
ARE APPRECIATE AND WE'RE
SUPPORT RESTORATION. LINE.
FIFTY THOUSAND- CHAIR WEEKLY
THERE'S AN ECHO WITH EVERYBODY
THAT CALLING IN FOR A MINUTE I
DON'T HAVE A COMMENT ON THAT
BUT IT VERY HARD TO HEAR RIGHT.
IN ORDER LINE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO TO
OPPOSITION TO SB SIX WE HAVE NO
ONE SIGNED UP AS A LEAD- WHEN
S. MRS ARE ZERO LEAD WITNESS
OKAY- OR YOU CAN BE A MILITARY
WHATEVER YOU WANT- SO GO AHEAD.
I WILL TALK VERY FAIRLY BUSY
BUT MARK STIVERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP
ALSO SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
PETER GOT OUT OF THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHO'S HAVING
DIFFICULTY GETTING RECOGNIZED
ON THE PHONE. OKAY HERE TO WE
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S INTENT
TO MAKE MORE LAND AVAILABLE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT GENERALLY HERE TOO
WE CONSIDER THE OFFER TO BE A
TRUE CHAMPION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND UNFORTUNATELY HERE
TO WE MUST OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED BECAUSE THE BILL
EFFECTIVELY CONTAINS A UNION
ONLY CONSTRUCTION REQUIREMENTS
AND AS I DISCUSSED PREVIOUSLY-
WE CAN WE HAVE A HARD TIME
GETTING COMPETITIVE BIDS NOW.
IF WE DISQUALIFIED HALF OF THE
WORKFORCE FROM BIDDING FOR
CONSTRUCTION JOBS WE WILL NOT
BE ABLE TO MOVE PROJECTS
FORWARD OR WILL BE SUBJECT TO
THE MARKET POWER OF A SINGLE
BIDDER- WE I THINK THAT THOSE
PROVISIONS RENDER THIS BILL
PARTICULARLY CHALLENGING TO USE
PARTICULARLY IN THOSE RURAL
AREAS REPRESENTED BY THE GOOD
SENATOR SO WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED- WE
ACTUALLY OFFER ONE FURTHER
AMENDMENT WHICH IS. THE BILL
CONTAINS AN AFFORDABILITY
REQUIREMENT THAT THAT REMAINS
BLANK- THIS BILL DOES WOULD
CREATE VALUE FOR THE DEVELOPERS
TO BUILD ADDITIONAL HOUSING WE
THINK SOME OF THAT VALUE SHOULD
BE RECAPTURED FOR THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT WITH A 20%
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENT WE.
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU- THANK YOU- MUCH- WE
APPARENTLY DO YOU HAVE AN ECHO
ON THE PHONE LINE SO WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A VERY. BRIEF PAUSE
NOT GONNA CALL TO RESET THE
PAUSE- SO. THAT I EIGHTEEN T.
CAN FIX THAT.
OKAY OKAY. BUT.
HEY CAN YOU HEAR US. YES I CAN
AND I'M JUST TESTING THE AUDIO
HERE NO ECHO FROM MY END OKAY
ON OUR END. IT'S CLEAR WHEN YOU
SPEAK PERFECT THANK YOU. WE
WILL START AGAIN- IT FOR FOLKS
IF THE EFFECT YEAH BECAUSE IT'S
STILL HAPPENING I'VE GOT A FEW
TEXT MESSAGES ME SO YOU CAN
JUST TEXT ME AGAIN LET ME KNOW
BUT HOPEFULLY IT'S FIXED NOW
OKAY- IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE GALLERY THAT WANTS TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AS WE SEXING NINE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE-
SAYING NINE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES OF THE MODERATOR
PLEASE QUEUE UP OPPONENTS. OF
IT SB SIX. THANK YOU THE STATE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL YOU MAY
PRESS THE ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO. WELL FIRST
ONLINE FORTY SEVEN OR SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN
BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
OPPOSITION. NEXT WE HAVE WON A.
ONE OKAY AFTERNOON SURE MEMBERS
DAN HUTCHINGS WITH THE PUBLIC
POLICY GROUP REPRESENTING THE
CITY OF CORONA NOT DECISION.
FIND. ONE TWENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MEMBERS ANGRY ANTS
WE WILL TRY AND ANSWER EACH
PROGRAM PLAYING HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO SB SIX. LINE ONE OF SEVEN.
WEARING A WHITE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM
RESPECTFUL BECAUSE UNLESS THE
MANAGER THE REASONS CAN
ABANDONED JUST AFTER THANK YOU.
ONE OH NINE. HI THIS IS SANDRA
WALLACE FROM THE MAGNOLIA
AVENUE RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION OF
THE MID PENINSULA AND WE
VEHEMENTLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
PINE FOURTEEN LINE IS OPEN.
SURELY LAUREN DELFI ALONG WITH
LITTLE BOOK CALIFORNIA HALLE
UNITED NEIGHBORS AND CATHOLIC
AYE OPPOSED IT SB SIX. NEXT WE
HAVE A LINE ONE TEN. RECALL
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA SB SIX WITH
NO AFFORDABLE HOUSING WILL
DISPLACE BELOVED MOM AND POP
STORES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY BLACK AND BROWN THE
BUSINESSES- AND- WE OPPOSE.
LINE TWENTY TWO TO TWO. LINE
TWENTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AFTER ALMOST A LINE SEVENTY
NINE SEVEN NINE. HELLO MY NAME
IS AN ICONIC INVENTION I AM NOT
RESIDENTIAL HOMEOWNER ON THE
WEST SIDE OF LA AND I'D LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT HIGH DENSITY
MULTI STORY BUILDINGS EQUATES
TO AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND- I
DON'T THINK THIS IS THE BEST
WAY TO. ACCOMPLISH THAT THANK
YOU. ONE ONE ELEVEN. YES MY
NAME IS ELIZABETH HENRY I'M
SPEAKING VOTE SAVE LAFAYETTE
RELATABLE CALIFORNIA ENTRY
KNIGHTED NEIGHBORS AND- I
AGREED WITH THE PREVIOUS CALLER
IT DOESN'T EQUATE AND THERE'S
NO PROOF THAT IT DOES I
STRONGLY OPPOSE. NEXT WE HAVE
LINE. ONE TWENTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
WITH AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION AND WOULD LIKE TO
ALIGN OUR COMMENTS WITH MISTER
STEINBERG AS WELL THANK YOU.
LINE. THIRTY ONE. HI THIS IS
SUSAN KIRSCH ON BEHALF OF
CATALYST WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL. NINE ONE ONE TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KIANA VALENTINE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES AND
URBAN COUNTIES OF CALIFORNIA IN
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION UNLESS
AMENDED AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
DOCTOR ON OUR CONCERNS. LINE.
EIGHTY RATHER PULL OUT THE
LEADING TO THE AVENUE-
PRESIDENT WEST LA- POSE A
HIGHER DENSITY DOES NOT EQUATE
WITH AFFORDABLE HEALTH. BLIND.
OH FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON THE
ASSEMBLY DOES ON BEHALF OF THE
TRI VALLEY CITIES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE ONE SEVENTEEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEETING
ONLY ABOUT LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
MANAGER ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF THOUSAND OAKS IN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. LINE. THIRTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN OF
THE- EMILY GABEL LUDDY PAST MAN
CITY OF BURBANK. YOU CAN'T FOR
LITTLE CALIFORNIA THE SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY THIS IS NOT
FOCUSING PARTICIPATED IN CANTON
SHOPPING MALL CENTER. ACCEL
INTO OTHER NEIGHBORS VERY MUCH.
FIND SPEAKER THANK YOU AGAIN
NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY AND THE
FACT OF YOUR OPPOSITION. NINE
FORTY TWO. I DID JACK AVERY ON
BEHALF OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA
THREE ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MARKS- GRAYSON TEACH P. THREE
AND ARE IN RESPECTFUL- OPPOSED
THAT MANDATE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NINE THIRTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON TRACY RYAN WELL
COUNTY RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA.
FOLLOWING TWELVE. THE NEW
JERSEY REVIEWER HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CITIES
FROM UP THE CONTROL UNITED
NEIGHBORS BILLABLE CALIFORNIA
AND SO MANY OTHER GROUPS
WATCHING AS YOU
UNCONSTITUTIONALLY TRY TO STOP
LOCAL. DEMOCRACY BY TAKING A-
PLEASE THANK YOU. BLIND. TWENTY
TWO. NINE THIRTY THREE. THREE
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU- WELL I AM REALLY GETTING
READY THE LITTLE CALIFORNIA YOU
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY WELL
INTENDED BUT THE AUTHOR NEEDS
TO WORK ON MY BILL. THANK YOU
WILL KNOW YOUR OPPOSITION. PINE.
EIGHT FIVE EIGHT. YES THIS IS
LISA MORRIS A RESIDENT OF- LA
CRESCENTA AND GLENDALE AND I DO
NOT SUPPORT A LOCAL ZONING
BEING CHANGED BY DEVELOPERS AND
I AGREE WITH RECALL COUNTY VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR OPPOSITION WILL
BE NOTED NEXT SPEAKER. AT THIS
TIME THEY'RE NOT FOR THE LINE
IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN
I BRING ABOUT THE COMMITTEE. HI
COLLEAGUES OF ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS RELATING TO SB SIX.
SENATOR CHAU. HELLO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR IN THANK YOU-
RIGHT HE'S FALLING. THANK YOU
SENATOR- CAREER FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE FOR WE RECEIVED A
LOT OF SUPPORT FROM OUR FOR MY
DISTRICT- WITH REGARDS TO THIS
BILL BUT I DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS AS FAR AS- SIMILAR
DISCUSSIONS AS TO IF THERE'S
BEEN ANY CONSIDERATION AT IN
PLACING. RESIDENTIAL UNITS
WITHIN INDUSTRIAL AREAS AND
HEALTH- IN THE LONG TERM AND
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS- I'LL
GIVE AN EXAMPLE AS REAL TORS WE
ARE SUPPOSED TO DISCLOSE ALL OF
THE AREAS YOU HAVE B. IF A
PROPERTY IS WITHIN A CERTAIN
AREA OF AN AIRPORT WITHIN A
CERTAIN AREA OF FARMLAND. AND
JUST OF PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT ENTAILS. WHAT THE
ENVIRONMENT WILL ENTAIL AND
THAT AND- HEY WE ALSO HEAR
QUITE A BIT AND I'VE HEARD THAT
FROM SEVERAL GROUPS. THE
CONCERNS THAT PEOPLE HAVE WHEN
THEY- HAVE- SAY WERE HOUSES
BEING UILT NEARBY RESIDENTIAL
AREAS AND HOW THAT AFFECTS
THEIR- THERE CAN THEIR QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR OTHER INDUSTRIAL
AREAS COMING INTO A CROUCHING
INTO THE RESIDENTIAL AREAS AND
NOW WE ARE. WITH THIS BILL.
TRYING TO APPROVE AB DE ABILITY
TO. BUILD RESIDENTIAL HOMES- IN
INDUSTRIAL AREAS- FOR AN
EXAMPLE I'M JUST CURIOUS AS TO
HAS THERE BEEN ANY
CONSIDERATION OR HER. OUR TALKS
ABOUT WHAT THAT IS GOING TO
LOOK LIKE IN THE LONG RUN FOR
THESE- INDUSTRIES THAT ARE
THERE WHAT'S GOING TO TAKE
PRIVATE IF THE HEALTH OF THE-
THE PEOPLE LIVING IN CHOOSING
TO LIVE HERE. OR THESE-
ENTITIES THAT WILL HAVE TO
RELOCATE- YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
YOUR MIND. THIRTY THROUGH THE
CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
SENATOR FOR THAT THOSE
QUESTIONS LET ME JUST SAY THAT-
I CAME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND SO I SPENT FIFTEEN YEARS IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND I HAVE A-
A REAL COMMITMENT. TO
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THEIR LOCAL
CONTROL SO THAT'S NUMBER ONE
NUMBER TWO IS THE BILL IN ITS
CURRENT FORM PROHIBITS ANY
DEVELOPMENT OF HOUSING ADJACENT
TO AN INDUSTRIAL AREA AND- I
RECEIVED A LETTER- OF IT WITHIN
THE PAST WEEK FROM RC RC THE
URBAN COUNTIES IN C. SECTOR
HAVE SOME REALLY GOOD-
SUGGESTIONS IN TERMS OF
CLARIFYING LANGUAGE TO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR. THAT THERE MAY BE
SOME PARCELS THAT ARE
COMMERCIAL THAT INCLUDE
INDUSTRIAL PARK A COMMERCIAL
THAT INCLUDE- THE KINDS OF
ZONING THAT YOU WOULDN'T WANT
TO PUT HOUSING NEXT TO AND WILL
MAKE IT VERY CEAR THAT WE
DON'T INTEND THAT TO HAPPEN
THAT'S NOT THE INTENTION OF THE
BILL THE BILL IS. PERMISSIBLE
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THEY
CAN IDENTIFY THE SITES THAT
THEY BELIEVE WILL BE MOST
APPROPRIATE FOR HOUSING THEY
WILL KNOW WHO WHAT SITES THEY
ARE BECAUSE THE STORES ARE
CLOSING THIS IS NOT AN ATTEMPT.
TO CLOSE. BUSINESSES THAT ARE
SUCCESSFUL. AND TO REPLACE THE-
THE LOT WITH HOUSING THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE AN
INVESTMENT IN A SHOPPING
CENTER. IN THE COMMERCIALS OWN
THAT WILL ALLOW HOUSING TO BE
PART OF THE OF THE MIXED USE IN
THE ZONE- AND SO WE'LL BE VERY
CAREFUL TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
DOESN'T- CONFLICT WITH OTHER
LAND USES THAT WOULD CREATE A
DANGER. BY PUTTING HOUSING NEXT
TO IT. AND SO THEY WERE WORKING
TOMORROW NIGHT AND THE LANGUAGE
WILL BE WILL WILL WILL WILL
WILL YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT YOU'LL
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY SEE IT.
WONDERFUL THANK YOU. HEY AT
WORK ANYTHING ELSE CENTER
TROUBLE. THANK YOU BYE CENTER
PATEL'S A- THE PROCORE THROUGH
THE BILL I'D BE HAPPY TO MOVE
IT AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE A MOTION ANY OTHER
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. OKAY
PERSONIFYING CENTER CABALLERO
FOR- FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
I'M PROUD TO BE A CO AUTHOR OF
AND I SUPPORT IT- TODAY- RIGHT
I DO JUST WANT TO KNOW ONE
THING AND- I APPRECIATE THE
SENATE ARE TALKING ABOUT SOME
OF THE CHANGES. IN TERMS OF
WORK FROM HOME AND WHAT THAT
MIGHT MEAN FOR COMMERCIALS HE
SAYS- AND THERE MAY BE
COMMERCIAL PLANS THAT YOU KNOW
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC AND
WORK FROM HOME. MAY NO LONGER.
BE AS NEAT AS A ONCE BEFORE I
DO I DO THIS WHEN I SAYS MY OWN
VIEW THAT FROM WHAT I'VE SEEN I
THINK THAT. THAT MAY NOT BE A
SIGNIFICANT A FACTOR AS WE
SOMETIMES THINK IMMERSING IN
THE BAY AREA EVEN FACEBOOK
GOOGLE ARE CONTINUING. TO
EXPAND- EVEN AS THEY HAVE MORE
FLEXIBLE WORK FROM HOME- I DO
THIS BILL EVEN PRE PANDEMIC-
THIS BILL WOULD BE INCREDIBLY
USEFUL UNIFICATION NUMBER CAT
AND- HAPPEN BECAUSE THE REALITY
IS WE HAVE A LOT OF LAND DAWSON
BAY AREA BUT- IN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- THAT'S EITHER UNDER
PERFORMING. ARTS US NOT BEING
DEVELOPED AS COMMERCIAL EVEN
THOUGH ITS OWN NOT WHEN WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. IS IT CREATES A
FACILITATOR WAY JUST TO CREATE
FLEXIBILITY SO BEYOND THE
ETERNAL DEBATES OR PARK AND
HAVE FOR YEARS AND YEARS ABOUT
THE IMPACTS OF THE PANDEMIC ON
ONE WORK IN OFFICE ETCETERA. I
THINK THIS BILL IS INCREDIBLY
USEFUL- AND HAVING THAT GREATER
FLEXIBILITY AND SO I'M PROUD TO
SUPPORT IT- SO- WITH THAT-
CENTER CAREER YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY THAT I
TESTIFIED HERE TODAY APPRECIATE
THEIR COMMENTS AND CONCERNS-
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE KNOW WE
pTO DO IT IN A WAY THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE THAT HAS AS- LITTLE
IMPACT ON THE NEIGHBORHOODS AS
POSSIBLE AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
DOES. SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU.
WITHOUT AMOUNT OF. YOU MAY CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS BILL SIX BUT
KERR THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE RE REFER TO THE CA ON
APPROPRIATE. SENATOR WIENER HI
WIENER AYE BATES NOT VOTING
IT'S NOT VOTING CABALLERO HI
CABALLERO HI CORTICES
KRITISIERT MCGUIRE. BUT CHAU
BOOK I SAW A BOOK I'D SKINNER
AYE SKINNER AYE NUMBER. HI
AMBER I WOULD CAL SKI. SIX
ZERO. OKAY THAT HAS ENOUGH
VOTES AND WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS WE WILL NOW
GO TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHT S. B.
EIGHT- BY CENTER SKINNER WHO
WILL PRESENT FROM HER. THE BEST.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND- EVERYONE I EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION TO THE
COMMITTEE OF FOR BEING WILLING
TO CROSS AS COMMITTEE AMENDS
SOME AUTHOR AMENDMENTS. THAT- I
AM- ATTY ST STE BESIDES
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP THOSE
DEMANDS AND ALL GET INTO THE
TECHNICAL CLEAN UP A LITTLE
LATER THOSE IMMENSE CLARIFY.
THAT ENTIRE DISPLACEMENT
PROTECTIONS APPLY TO LOWER
INCOME OCCUPANTS AND EXCLUDE
SHORT TERM RENTALS. AND NOW TO
THE BILL SB EIGHT SO HE WENT TO
STATE YOUR PAST SB THREE THIRTY
IN TWENTY. NINETEEN AND THAT
BILL THREE THIRTY WHICH THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW HAS
REALLY ASSISTED THE CALIFORNIA
IN GETTING MORE HOUSING BUILT.
THE BILL HAS A VERY I THINK OUR-
PRACTICAL BUT ESSENTIAL PURPOSE
WHICH IS THAT IT HELPS TO
GREENLIGHT THOSE HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT MEET OUR EXISTING
RULES NOW WE ALREADY HAVE OTHER
STATUTES ON THE BOOK THAT HELPS
TO DO THAT HOWEVER. WE WATCHED
THAT PROJECTS WERE MOVING
FORWARD AND THEN A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WOULD CHANGE ITS
RULES WHICH THEN WOULD EITHER
ELIMINATE THE BILL WOULD BE FOR
THAT HOUSING PROJECT WHICH
PREVIOUSLY MET THE RULES TO GO
FORWARD OR GREATLY DELAY IT. ON
SO WHAT SB THREE THIRTY DID AND
WHAT I WILL EXPLAIN SB EIGHT
DOES IS SB THREE THIRTY SAID
LOOK WE'RE IN A CRISIS RIGHT
NOW LET'S JUST TAKE A PAUSE AND
LET'S. STOP CHANGING THE RULES
FOR FIVE YEARS LET'S STOP
CHANGING THE RULES LET'S HOLD
OFF ON ACTIONS THAT DELAY OR
DECREASE HOUSING YOU KNOW OUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PARTNERS AND
ALLOW THOSE HOT THAT HOUSING
WHICH WE HAD ALREADY WE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. HAVE ACCEPTED AND
SAID WAS MEET OUR ROLES LET'S
LET HIM GO FORWARD. NOW BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC AS WE ALL KNOW
MANY THINGS HAVE BEEN HALTED.
SO WHAT SB EIGHT DOES IS IT
EXTENDS THE LIFE OF SB THREE
THIRTY SO S. THREE THIRTY AS I
MENTIONED WAS JUST YOU KNOW
GIVE US FIVE YEARS TO TRY TO
ACCELERATE THE HOUSING THAT
MEETS OUR RULES. BUT BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC PAUSE WHAT I WANT
TO DO AND I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME
TO DO IS EXTEND THE PROVISIONS
OF SB THREE THIRTY UNTIL TWENTY
THIRTY SO IT WOULD STILL
EXPIRED IT WOULD STILL GO AWAY
BUT WE WOULD AT LEAST BE ABLE
TO FOR THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
HAVE OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MOVE
FORWARD WITH THAT HOUSING THAT
MEETS THEIR RULES AND NOT
CHANGE THE RULES MIDSTREAM AND
NOT TAKE ACTIONS THAT DECREASE
OR DELAYED HOUSES. NOW THE FEW
CHANGES TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
THAT WE'VE INCLUDED THIS THAT
ARE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT'S IN THREE THIRTY ARE THAT
WE LOOK HER FOR LOW GUY IN THE
TO YOU THAT THREE THREE A BEEN
OP. THAT THE WERE FEW. THAT
WERE. IN PERHAPS THE HARD TO IN
THE SO WE BE SOME FOR A MEMBER
TO DEATH. AND AROUND THE OF LOW
AND CAN UNITS SO THAT THE BILL
NOT THIS. LOW INCOME FIVE LOWER
RESIDENTS AND NOW I WOULD LIKE
MY WITNESSES GOBBLED FROM THE
NONPROFIT HOUSING ASSOCIATION
OF NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
JONATHAN FERN FROM GREYSTAR
DEVELOP. TO S. B. THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER WILL NOT GO LEAD
SUPPORT JOHN FOR FROM. GREYSTAR
UNPAID ABOUT FROM MPA- AND
AGAIN YOU HAVE TO. TOTAL OF
FOUR PLEASED YOU INTO THE WITH
A TO- MAY PRESS. ASSEMBLY.
POLITIKA PUSHED ABILITY. TO DID
NOT GO OKAY- WELL GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE WINNER- MY IS
JOE BYRNE I IN ADDITION. TO BE
MANINDER- UPON THE GRACE REAL
HOUSING BILLS HERE IN THE BAY
MALLS. COMMISSIONER OF VOCAL
ABOARD OF THE CASINO CALL-
CENTERS HERE MISSION OPENING OR-
THAT CAN. STILL VERY MUCH IN A
HOUSE CRISIS BECAUSE THOUGHT
THE BILL THE HOUSE. DURING THE
DEVELOPMENT. BETTER PRINCIPLE
UNDER LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO
DIXON'S OWNING LAWS GET
APPROVED IN A TIMELY MATTER.
IT'S CRITICAL TO MAXIMIZING THE
ALREADY LIMITED NUMBER FUNDING
SOURCES DEVELOP HOUSING
DEVELOPERS. PARTICULAR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPERS
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT
PROJECTS ACTUALLY GET FINISHED
OR DELAYED OFTEN SHOW UP AS
INCREASES IN THE COST OF THE
UNIT WHICH IS THEN PASSED ON TO
THE FIRE. UNIFIED EVEN REACHES
COMPLETION AS MANY DEVELOPERS
DON'T HAVE THE BUDGET. TO
SUPPORT- EXTENDED TIMELINE AND
SIMPLY CANCEL THE PROJECT. BOB
THE I PERSONALLY HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN A PROJECT THAT THE
CONFORM TO GENERAL PLAN ZONING
CRITICAL FOR SEVEN YEARS TO
ENTITLE. YEAH THAT WAS ONLY
DONE- BY REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
UNITS BY HALF. CONVERSELY
RECENTLY I'VE BEEN CUT BEEN
INVOLVED IN THREE PROJECTS
UTILIZING SB THREE THIRTY. IN
THE QUERY PROCESSES PRIESTESS
ACCRETION OF NOT ONLY BY US BUT
BY CITY STAFF AS WELL. FIFTY
THREE THIRTY PROVIDING THE
CERTAINTY AND COMBINED WITH
OTHER HOUSING- STATE HOUSING
LAWS. HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL IN
GETTING MANY NONPROFIT MIXED
INCOME AND MARKET RATE HOUSING
PROJECTS APPROVED BONE FIVE
HEARINGS. IN A CLEARER MORE
RATIONAL COMPLETE. THIS PROCESS
AT THE FRONT. SB EIGHT BILLS
ARE THE PRODUCT THE PRODUCT
PROGRESS SB THIRTY PROVIDES
RESEARCH. MICHAEL GOVE BUT LIKE.
THE FRONT THAT. TWENTY THIRTY
CLARIFYING TERM AGREEMENT FOR
THE HOUSE PRODUCTION. BASE IN
THE BENEFITS IMPROVING CLARITY
OF HOUSING CRASH BACK. IF YOU
DO TO. DURING A CRUDE AND
MICHAEL STAFF IN TACKLING HOW
ARE GOING HOUSING. WITH BATTERS
ASK YOUR SUPPORT SB EIGHT THANK
YOU CONSIDERING. OKAY I MISS
ABOUT YOUR MINUTE AND FIVE.
LATE BOXING YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
EFFORT TO TRAVEL THANK FOR
PAYING MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE.
IT TOOK OUT ALL POLL DIRECT
KAMAL HAS OCCASIONALLY CAROL
I'M CALLING STRONG OF SB EIGHT
BY SENATOR SKINNER WHICH WILL
CONTINUE COOKS SB TWO THIRTY BY
IN. AND LOCAL THE PROCESS CALL
THE NINETEEN TEN THEN THE KIDS
EACERBATES ARE HOW YOU MIGHT.
AND HOW DO BUSINESS PARK AGREED.
I HAVE A PORTABLE TO CALL THE A
SPADE FAMILY TO BE FAMILIES TO
HEAL AND. HOW DEVELOPMENT ALL I
THE BALL THE FUTURE BY LOCAL
GROUPS YET IN THE- PROJECTS
WITHIN THE- SOMETIMES FOR YOU.
ARBITRAL CHANGES LOCAL. EVEN
AFTER PROJECT IS APPROVED. SB
THREE THIRTY CLEAN PROJECT. IN
THE HOUSE CORPORATE PROCESS I
HOPE TO THE ANTI HEIGHT THEM
DEVELOP HAVE BEEN. INCLUDING
PREDICT PRIME. HE'S PROCESS
CREWS TO GET DESPERATE NEEDED A
HOME BUILT FOR INSTANCE. EACH
MEMBER MAKE PENN HOUSING THE
LAW TO. NONPROFIT THEIR- WHICH
IS A THE OTHER AND CONCERTS GO
WHICH WILL COME A HUNDRED
THIRTY FORTY HOMES WERE EDGING.
I'M AS STATE. ON THE TO
RECOVERY IT'S CALL THAT YOU
CONTRIBUTE SUPPORT. AND I PER
YOU TO PLEASE SUPPORT EIGHT.
COMMITTEE PROTECT. AND HOW HI
APPROVAL PROCESS BETTER.
DESPERATELY NEEDED CONTINUE
ADDRESS. HOUSING CRISIS AND
WITHOUT A RISK WITH I. OR
ANYONE ELSE IN THE SENATE
GALLERY IN SUPPORT SAYING NINE
WILL GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. MON
TWELVE THERE'S NO ONE THERE
NUMBER OF THE PHONE LINES OR
THE MODERATOR PLEASE QUEUE UP
SUPPORT FOR SB. EIGHT STATE
YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. LOCAL FIRSTLINE.NINETY
ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON SILVIO
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF FACEBOOK
IN SUPPORT. NINE ONE THREE.
RIGHT UNDER WITH PROPERTY
RECEIVERS ON BEHALF OF
SCHNEIDER ELECTRIC NORTH
AMERICA AND ONE OF THE BILL.
ONE FIFTY ONE. MONTEREY WITHOUT
IN THE- IN SUPPORT. ONE FIFTY
THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON JUSTIN
HIGHER FROM TALK ABOUT
LEADERSHIP GROUP PROJECTS FOR
THE BILL THANK YOU. ONE TWENTY
NINE. HOLLY FOR ME THEY HAD TO
THE WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT
TODAY ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA BURKE HIM
HE PARTNERED A COPY TO
COALITION THE COUNCIL OF INFILL
BUILDERS SAND HILL PROPERTY
COMPANY AS WELL AS THE GREEN
LINING INSTITUTE. ALL IN
SUPPORT. LINE. EIGHTY SOUTH
RIPLEY CALLING FROM IN SUPPORT
BUT AUTHORED AN AMENDMENT THAT
THEIR REQUIREMENTS FOR
REPLACEMENT OF DEMOLITION UNIT
AUTHOR OF WHY YOU STATE
AGENCIES BUT THAT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA THANK
YOU. ONE THIRTY FOUR. WHEN THE
REYNOLDS OF CALIFORNIA ADVISORS
ON BEHALF OF ZILLOW IN SUPPORT.
ONE THIRTY FIVE. THIS IS THE
BEGINNING- UNION CITY CALLING
WITH THE STATE EVERYONE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THIRTY FIVE.
ANY BAN ON BEHALF OF BRIDGE
HOUSING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE TWENTY TWO. GOOD MORNING
AND AN AFTERNOON I MET A
BOOKBINDER CAMPBELL BANKERS
DISTRICT FIFTEEN CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE INDIAN EXPORT SB
EIGHT. ONE OF SEVEN. FIND. ONE
THE GOOD FORTUNE IN SUPPORT.
ONE FORTY NINE- TOBY MARSHON A
WITH WEBSITE FOR EVERYONE LOS
ANGELES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE THIRTY THREE. MICHAEL
BECKER- FROM CASTRO VALLEY AND
DONE IN SUPPORT OF THIS AND SB
SIX. THANK YOU. SEVENTY FIVE.
LINE SEVENTY FIVE SEVEN FIVE
YEAR OPEN. FOR MOST TO LINE.
FIFTY SEVEN. CHAIRED MEMBERS-
THAT BOWLING WITHOUT FOR
EVERYONE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. TWENTY TWO. YES
CAN HEARING OPEN. MORNING
GETTING MY NAME'S. CALLING
JERRY FROM THE START LINE AND
HUNDRED AND MARK HENRY AND WE
ARE AND. AND- HAPPENED PROBABLY
HAPPENED A THANK YOU THINK OF
IT ON THE THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. NINE ONE TWENTY.
HELLO MY NAME IS ON A P. O. D.
SHOW- FROM CENTER THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
TWENTY NINE SENATE-DISTRICT
SIXTEEN IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY FOUR.
HELLO THIS IS BOB NAYLOR FOR
FIELD SAID IN COMPANY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT. ONE
FIFTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON IF
YOU LOOK AT THE AGREEMENT ON
BEHALF OF SILICON VALLEY AT
HOME STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ONE FIFTY SIX. LINE ONE FIFTY
SIX YOUR MIND OF THE FIRST BACK
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS ALSO
IMPORTANT. ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
TELL YOU CALLING FOR THE
BEARISH COUNSEL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. ONE FIFTY EIGHT.
UPDATE CHAIRED MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE OUT OF READ THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AT THE PORT THANK YOU. ONE
SIXTY. GOOD AFTERNOON RICHARD
MEMBERS MICHAEL GUNNING HERE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ONE SIXTY FOUR. DEPUTY ENGINEER
NUMBERS STARTING CRIMESON
BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA YOUNG
DEMOCRATS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT. COLONEL FOR THE LINE
TO CONTINUE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY LEAD
I'D MEET OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED
SB EIGHT SO WE WILL. START OUT
HERE IN THE SENATE AND THE
SENATE CHAMBERS I DON'T SEE
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY WILL NOW
GO TO ROOM ONE TWELVE. BY
SAYING NO ONE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES WERE NOW IN
OPPOSITION. S. B. BATES. THE
STATE OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
ME PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
PHONE. WELL THE FIRST ONLINE.
ONE TWENTY SIX. SHARE MEMBERS
INJURY ON TWENTY CLEAR ONLY
HALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
NINE ONE TEN. RECALL LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA CUTTING THE VOICE OF
THE PEOPLE BY LIMITING HEARING
THIS SHOULD NOTBE EXTENDED TO
TWENTY THIRTY FOR LUXURY
SPECULATORS OPPOSE SB. EIGHT
NINE SEVENTY NINE. LINE SEVEN
NINE SEVENTY NINE. HOME OF THE
LINE FOURTEEN. SURELY LAUREN
DALKEY ALONG WITH LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA KELLY KATELYN AND
UNITED NEIGHBORS I STRONGLY
OPPOSED SB EIGHT. FIFTY EIGHT.
NINE FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. WILL MOVE THE LINE.
THIRTY THREE. THREE THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HOME OF THE LINE
FOR ROUNDUP AND- ONE FORTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I MEAN
BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. LINE. ONE
SEVENTEEN. ONE ONE SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WELCOME ONE AND
ALL. ONE FORTY SEVEN ONE FOUR
SEVEN. HI WEBER BRUSQUELY
RESIDENT LINCOLN AVENUE WEST LA
ABOUT. FIND. ONE SIXTY THREE.
HI THIS IS SUSAN KIRSCH ON
BEHALF OF CATALYST WE ARE
CLOSED ON THE BILL EIGHT. THANK
YOU. LINE. FIFTY FOUR. FIVE
FORTY ONE OF THE OPEN. BORN A
RESIDENT REDONDO BEACH REMEMBER
UNITED NEIGHBORS IN OPPOSITION
TO SB EIGHT THANK YOU. WIND.
ONE ELEVEN. ELIZABETH HENRY
LIVABLE CALIFORNIA KELLY SAY
LAFAYETTE STRONGLY OPPOSED IN I
REALLY WISH THAT CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC STATE LEGISLATURE
WOULD STOP LYING TO THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. LINE. ONE SIXTY TWO. ONE
SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
BERMAN BONTA LINE. ONE FIFTY
NINE ONE FIVE NINE. HI JILL
STUART ANGELENOS FOR TREES AND
THE GLOBAL CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T
THINK YOU SHOULD PUT IN HOUSTON
HOME SET ON THE VERY MUCH.
NOTED LINE ONE OWNER ONE ZERO
NINE. SH THIS IS SANDRA WALLACE
FROM THE MAGNOLIA AVENUE
RESIDENTS ASSOCIATION OF THE
MID PENINSULA AREA ND WE FEEL.
OPPOSED THE SPELL. TURN OFF FOR
THE LINES IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL BRING THE BILL
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE COLORS
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. WHERE DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. A SENATOR CORTEZ. I
WANT TO THANK YOU GUYS CENTER
SKINNER FOR HERVERY VERY HARD
WORK. ON SB THREE THIRTY- I
MEAN THAT WAS A LONG AND
COMPLICATED. PROCESS BUT THIS
BILL HAS BEEN DESCRIBED- THIS
LAW SHOULD SAYS BEEN DESCRIBED
AS ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
AND IMPACTFUL HOUSING LAWS IN.
RECENT YEARS IT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY A GOOD
GOVERNMENT- LAW TO SAYING YOU
CAN HAVE WHATEVER RULES YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE- BUT HE CAN BE WE
NEED TO MOVE AWAY FROM.
CALIFORNIA'S TYPICAL ROPE A
DOPE- A HOUSING PROCESS WHERE
IT'S OF SUCH TURBULENT
UNPREDICTABLE AN OPEN ENDED
PROCESS AND TO SET SOME
GUARDRAILS SO THERE'S A
BEGINNING MIDDLE AND END. OF
THE PROCESS AND I THINK SB
THREE THIRTY DOES NOT VERY
GRACEFULLY- AND- THIS
LEGISLATION AND MAKING SYSTEM
NEEDED CLARIFICATIONS- AND
EXTENDING THE SUNSET I THINK IS
VERY IMPORTANT SO I SUPPORT THE
BILL- AND- I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE. ACTUALLY THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS AND I CAN'T REMEMBER
IF YOU ACCEPTED THE AMOUNT I
DID YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR OKAY WITHOUT WE DO HAVE
A- MOTION MY CENTER CORTEZ THE
AND CENTER IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANKS SO MUCH- AND
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS- BY THE
CHAIR AND- I DIDN'T SAY THIS IN
THE REASONS. WHY THIS BILL SO
IMPORTANT BUT I THINK. WHAT I
MEAN BEYOND THE FACT THAT WE
HAVE A- CRISIS WE HAVEN'T FOR.
CRISIS AND WE KNOW. THAT THE
LADY'S DASH COST. DELAY MAKES
HOUSING MORE EXPENSIVE AND IT
MAKES IT LESS AFFORDABLE SO AS
WE HEARD FROM THE KEY WITNESS
IN SUPPORT OF THE NONPROFIT
HOUSING ASSOCIATION OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AS MUCH AS WE HEAR
FROM SO MANY CONSTITUENTS HOW
MUCH THEY SUPPORT ONLY
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IT IS
ACTUALLY OUR AFFORDABLE
PROJECTS THAT TAKE THE LONGEST
TIME TO GET THROUGH THE
PROCESS. SO IN FACT WHAT IS THE
EXTENSION OF OUR HOUSING CRISIS
ACT BY ALLOWING THOSE. HOUSING
PROJECTS THAT MEET THE RULES TO
MOVE FASTER THROUGH THE PROCESS
IT WILL ACTUALLY HELP GET US
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS
FASTER AND WITH THAT I ASKED
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. GREAT THANK
YOU- WE HAVE A MOTION ON S. B.
AIDS ANDS LEARNING CONSULTANT
COULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS SENATE BILL EIGHT BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATOR WIENER. HI WIENER AYE
BATES STILL BATES NO CABALLERO
HI CABALLERO COURTESY COURTESY
I'D MCGUIRE. MITCHELL BOOK HI
THE CHORE BURKE AYE SKINNER HI
SKINNER I NUMBER ALL RIGHT
NUMBER FIVE WOOD COUNTY. SIX TO
ONE OKAY THAT IS ENOUGH VOTE
WILL PUT IRAN CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS- BY NOW WANTS TO- WE'RE
GONNA GO TO- ITEM NINE IS TO
TWELVE EXTERNAL MCGUIRE SENATOR
WELCOME AND I DO I DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT. BOND FOR THE FIRST
TEN WELL YOU ARE NOT THE WINNER
OF THE MIKE WEIR HONORARY AWARD
I THINK SENATOR WHITE CAL SKI
IS GOING TO WIN THAT AWARD
TODAY SO CONGRATULATIONS. ON
NOT WINNING THAT AWARD. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AT
THE CENTER MY CASKET I'VE BEEN
BUDGETS OF TWO AND A VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT. I UNDERSTAND
THAT YOU BY LUNCH I EACH TIME
FOR THE AWARD WINNERS SO YOU
ONLY IF YOU WANT TO. HAVE SO I
THINK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
INTO THE COMMITTEE. I'M
GRATEFUL TO BE HERE TODAY I
WANT TO START OFF BYSAYING I'M
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. TO CLARIFY THAT THE
BILL ONLY APPLIES TO VERY HIGH
FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY ZONES.
INTO TIED THE BILL THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN OFF THE PLANE
RESEARCH TECHNICAL ADVISORY.
MEMBERS I DON'T THINK WE NEED
TO HAVE MUCH OF A CONVERSATION
REGARDING THE UNPRECEDENTED
TIMES THAT. WE'RE LIVING IN
WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES TO
WILDFIRES THAT THINK WERE IN
AGREEMENT. THAT THE SIZE AND
SCOPE OF WILDFIRES IN THE STATE
HAVE CHANGED THE FACE OF
CALIFORNIA FOREVER. THE LARGER
THE MORE DESTRUCTIVE. THEY'RE
DEADLIER NOW THE NAME EVER BEEN
IN MODERN HISTORY. THE TWENTY
TWENTY WILDFIRE SEASON BURNED
MORE THAN FOUR POINT TWO.
MILLION ACRES. MAKING IT BY FAR
THE LARGEST IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. EIGHT OF THE TEN
LARGEST WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY. OCCURRED INTHE PAST
TEN YEARS. FOUR OUT OF THE FIVE
LARGEST WILDFIRES. HAPPENED
LAST YEAR ALONE. THIS INCLUDES
THE OBVIOUS COMPLEX FIRE WHICH
BURNED OVER ONE MILLION ACRES
IN SEPTEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
ON THE NORTH COAST. MAKING IT
THE FIRST FIRE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY TO BURN OVER ONE
MILLION ACRES. OF GORGEOUS
FORCING. AND WE ALL REMEMBER
THE CAMPFIRE NEW NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WHICH TRAGICALLY
BECAUSE THE DEATHS OF EIGHTY
SIX PEOPLE. DESTROYED NINETEEN
THOUSAND STRUCTURES. WHAT ABOUT
THE NORTH BAY FIRESTORM. IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DOZENS OF
LIVES WERE LOST. ALONG WITH
OVER SIX THOUSAND HOMES. IN IN
EACH OF THESE MAJOR FIRES TENS
OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS
RAN FOR THEIR LIVES. MANY TIMES
IN THE DARK OF NIGHT. THE WAY
WE STRATEGICALLY GROW GROW OUR
COMMUNITIES HAS ALSO COME INTO
QUESTION IS THE REALITY OF MAKE
A FIRE HAVE SITTING HERE THE
GOLDEN STATE. WE KNOW THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES IN HIGH
RISK AREAS MUST CHANGE. AND IF
THEY DON'T BEING VERY CANDID
MORE DEATH. AND DESTRUCTION
WILL FOLLOW. IN FACT THE
CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE HAS ALREADY INTERVENED
WITH LAWSUITS AND THREE LARGE
LARGE DEVELOPMENTS. HI TECHS IN
THE WILDLAND URBAN INTERFACE
BECAUSE OF WILDFIRE IMPACTS.
THE NEW NORMAL HERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE. IT'S HERE AND
IT'S NOT GOING AWAY WHICH IS
WHY WE ADVANCE SB TWELVE THIS
BILL SETS A MINIMUM FLOOR FOR
DEVELOPMENTS IN THE WILD IN
URBAN AIR INTERFACE CURRENT
STATE STANDARDS ARE LIMITED TO
THE BUILDING CODE. IN
REQUIREMENTS FOR ROAD SIGNS IN
FUEL BREAKS S. B. TWELVE SET UP
A TRANSFORMATIONAL PROCESS FOR
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL TO
ESTABLISH BOLD NEW STANDARDS.
THAT ENSURES DEVELOPMENTS AS A
WHOLE ARE DESIGNED DESIGNED TO
WITHSTAND WILDFIRE NOT JUST THE
BUILDINGS WITHIN THOSE
DEVELOPMENTS I WANT TO GIVE YOU
A COUPLE EXAMPLES WHAT THE
STANDARDS MAY INCLUDE. A
WILDFIRE OF WILDLAND FIRE
HAZARD ASSESSMENT IN WILDFIRE
HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN
STANDARDS FOR THE ORGANIZATION
DEPLOYMENT OF FIRE SUPPRESSION
OPERATIONS. LOCATION
CONSTRUCTION OF INFRASTRUCTURE
TO REDUCED IGNITION POTENTIAL
ENSURE AVAILABILITY OF WATER
ESSENTIAL FOR FIRE SUPPRESSION
DURING A WILDFIRE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
FUEL MODIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
IN AN ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM
ESTABLISHED FUNDED AND
IMPLEMENTED. TO VERIFY ONGOING
COMPLAINTS BACK BY FINANCING
MECHANISMS SUCH AS H. AWAY
FUNDS SITE SPECIFIC SAFETY
MEASURES TO ENSURE THAT THE
DEVELOPMENT AS A WHOLE IS PLANT
IS CURRENTLY CONSTRUCTED TO
RESISTING CULTURING OF
UNCONTROLLED FIRE. DEVELOPMENT
LAYOUT DEVELOPMENT LAYOUT THAT
REDUCES WILDFIRE RISK. TO THE
GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE.
BLUNTLY PUT THIS LEGISLATION
THAT IF DEVELOPMENT CAN'T MEET
STANDARD. LOCALS SHOULD NOT
APPROVED. BUT WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL. THE
STANDARDS ARE TIERED SET THE
STANDARDS INCREASINGLY STRONGER
AS DEVELOPMENTS GROW LARGER IN
THOSE HIGH FIRE HAZARD SEVERITY
ZONES THE REASON IS THIS LARGER
DEVELOPMENTS PUT MORE PEOPLE
INTO THE WORLD. AND SO THEY
MUST MEET HIGHER STANDARDS AND
SMALLER DEVELOPMENTS THIS MEANS
THAT THE REQUIREMENTS ARE
STRINGENT BUT NOT SO COSTLY AS
TO TOTALLY PREVENT DEVELOPMENT
WHICH BY THE WAY IS A
SIGNIFICAN AND THEN IN. THAT WE
ARE TAKING AFTER FEEDBACK FROM
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S OFFICE. AND
WE KNOW THAT HALF OF THE
BUILDINGS LOST OVER THE LAST
DECADE WERE IN THE WILL BE.
BUILT UNDER CURRENT FIRE CODES.
THIS BILL ALSO ENHANCES THE
PLANNING THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MUST DO INCLUDING TO COME UP
WITH A STRATEGY TO RETROFIT
EXISTING BUILDINGS. NOW THERE
ARE SOME THERE'S SOME HOPE TO
DO ABOUT THIS BILL BUT I LIKE
TO BE A TO TALK ABOUT THE
FACTS. THIS BILL IS ALMOST
IDENTICAL TO A BILL THAT WAS
APPROVED BY A BIPARTISAN
MAJORITY IN BOTH HOUSES AND
SENT TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK.
LIKE  SAID WE MADE AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS THE GOVERNOR'S
CONCERNS. MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE SUPPORTED. NEARLY AN
IDENTICAL BILL SB ONE EIGHTY
TWO LAST YEAR. THE PROPONENTS
ON THIS BILL WERE NEUTRAL ON
THE LEGISLATION WHICH IS NEARLY
IDENTICAL LAST YEAR. AND OTHER
CONCERNS THIS YEAR ARE WITH THE
PROVISIONS THE BILL THAT ARE
THE SAME PROVISIONS THAT WERE
CONTAINED IN THE BILL LAST YEAR.
SO WHAT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
DO IS THIS. WE BELIEVE THAT SB
TWELVE SB TWELVE WILL SAVE
LIVES SB TWELVE SAYS THAT THE
WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION
REDUCTION STANDARDS MUST BE
QUOTE.REASONABLE FEASIBLE AND
ACHIEVABLE FOR THE MAJORITY OF
DEVELOPMENTS IN EACH CATEGORY.
THIS ISN'T A QUESTION OF
INTERPRETATION IT'S BLACK AND
WHITE. IN THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL MUST GO THROUGH THE
FULL FORMAL RULE MAKING PROCESS
TO DEVELOP THE STANDARDS. I AM
IN INDIA RIGHT HERE IN SAY
THIS. THAT WE HAVE BEEN MEETING
WITH OPPOSITION FOR THE CAST
PASSED SEVERAL MONTHS. YOU HAVE
MIGHT ONE HUNDRED AND 10%
PROMISE RING TO CONTINUE TO
MEET WITH OPPOSITION. IN
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH AS I
ALWAYS DO FOR THE PAST SIX
YEARS IN THIS LEGISLATURE. WELL
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO REACH
FULL AGREEMENT YET. WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE IN GOOD FAITH. THIS
IS THE THIRD YEAR OF THIS BILL
IN THE LEGISLATURE. IN SB ONE
EIGHTY TWO IS THE ONLY BILL
THAT POUND SB TWELVE IS THE
ONLY BILL THAT BALANCES THE
NEED FOR NEW HOUSING EVEN IN
THE WILL BE WITH FIRE SAFETY.
AT THE BILL MEMBERS IS
SUPPORTED BY THE AMERICAN
PLANNING ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS CALIFORNIA FIRE
DISTRICTS. THE NATIONAL FIRE
PROTECTION ASSOCIATION AND
OTHERS. EMERG GRATEFUL THAT WE
HAVE WARRANTED. DEFENSE
DEVELOPMENTS HERE ON THE LINE
WITH THE AMERICAN PLANNING
ASSOCIATION. AS WELL AS CHIEF
DANCE THE FINAL HE'S THE
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
FIRE CHIEFS ASSOCIATION. MISTER
CHAIR I APOLOGIZE BUT GOING ON
TO LONG WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE IN. RESEARCHER
TRULY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
ENGAGEMENT THANK YOU TO YOUR
AMAZING STAFF TEAM. AARON HAS
BEEN WONDERFUL TO WORK WITH AS
WELL. THANK YOU SO MUCH- CENTER
THANK YOU FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS BILL- SO WE WILL NOW GO
TO. SUPPORT OUR LEAD SUPPORTERS
ARE LAUREN DIFERENCIA FROM THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION.
AND THEN- CHIEF DOWN SOPRANO
FROM THE FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND COST COSTA MESA
FIRE DEPARTMENT- SO- AGAIN IT'S
TWO MINUTES EACH ABOUT FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL SO- THE FIRST
WITNESS SHOULD BE MINDFUL. NOT
TO EAT INTO THE SECOND
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES. ARMS
START WITH- LAUREN DILLON ZERO
FOLLOWED BY MUCH YOU SEVERAL.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS
AREN'T ABLE AND REPRESENTS THE
PLANNING. PLEASE BAKER AND OR
THAT THE TWELVE WHICH WILL MAKE
A NUMBER COMPANIES CHANGES
OCCUR PLAN FOR AND FROM
DEVELOPMENT AND HIGH RISK AREAS.
WE ALREADY KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA
IS LIKELY TO FACE ANOTHER VERY
CHALLENGING WILDFIRE SEASON
PARTICULARLY IN LIGHT OF THE
RECORD DRY CONDITIONS AND
DROUGHT EMERGENCY CONDITION-
AND BADLY AS SENATOR REQUIRE
HAS THAT CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO FACE RECORD. BREAKING
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY FIRES
THAT HAVE BECOME THE STATE IN
NORMAL BILLING TURNED WE
BELIEVE THAT JURISDICTION'S
WILL NEED TO DO MORE TO BETTER
PREPARE AND PLANNING FOR
CLIMATE CHANGE RESILIENCY HAVE
LONG BEEN ON THE TOP OF MIND
FOR THE PLANNING PROFESSION AND
OVER THE YEARS IT'S BECOME
CLEAR THAT BOLD NEW STEPS NEED
TO BE TAKEN TO BETTER PREPARE
OUR COMMUNITY UNLIGHTED BUOYS.
INSURTECH RECORD SETTING
WILDFIRES THAT MEANS THAT WE
CASTING A LAND USE PLANNING IS
DONE IN THE WHAT HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS BUILDING RESILIENT HOME
AND ENSURING THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE SUPPORTED
WITH GUIDANCE AND FUNDING ARE
ALL CRITICAL STUFF THAT ARE
NEEDED. EIGHTY CALIFORNIANS
THEM. OF A WHILE REDUCTION. AND
REQUIRE THE BILL ENSURE THAT IT.
HOME PARDONS YOU DEVELOPMENTS
ARE. CONSIDERED AN PREPARE. WE
ALSO BELIEVE AT THE- HELLO
HOUSING PRIORITIES FOR MARC.
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PRACTICES
APPROPRIATE DESIGNED COMMUNITY
AND HE'S FIRE AREA. AB ONE POP.
DIRECTLY INTO THE LEFT HAS
AREAS WITHIN A- ALL OF THIS
WILL MEAN THE STATE'S HOUSING.
TARGETS FOR EACH REGION TO
ENSURE THE NEED TO DEVELOP A
PLEASE NOT HOUSING ARE BEING
DEVELOPED IN THE COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT. AND FINALLY WE
BELIEVE THAT THE REQUIRE.
APPLE'S LIVE LOCAL THE FACT
THAT LOCAL AND- STANDARDS.
FUNDING OR ALL PEOPLE WILL BE
THERE'S STILL ACCEPTING.
PLANNING MUST BE DONE NOW TO
HOMES AND LOW. BY PROVIDING FOR
MORE. COMMUNITIES WE REALLY
APPRECIATE REQUIRE AFTER WHILE
THE CHAIR AND THE- ON THAT. AND
LOOK FORWARD TO ASKING BILL
AFTER HEARING THE IT THE BACKUP.
MICHAEL YOUNG. NEXT IN. OF THIS
CHIEF DOWN STEP BY. YES WELL
THANK YOU IN AFTERNOON TO AND
MEMBER OF THE COULD MY NAME IS
DAN TO FOLLOW CHIEF FOR THE
CITY BECAUSE TO ME AND PRESS OF
THE FOR CHIEFS. IT AGAIN WANT
TO THANK SENATOR FOR EFFORTS-
THEY ARE OF. AS WE ARE ALL TO
CALIFORNIA HAS A LARGEST MOST
IS WILDFIRE THE WILDFIRES OVER
THE LAST DECADE DEVASTATED
COMMUNITIES LARGE AND SMALL.
MILLIONS OF HOMES FACE SERIOUS
RISK OF DESTRUCTION FROM
WILDFIRE. AND THIS NUMBER
CONTINUES TO RISE AS WE ATTEMPT
TO BUILD OURSELVES OUT OF THE
STATE'S HOUSING SHORTAGE. AS WE
WORK COLLABORATIVELY TO ADDRESS
THE STATE'S HOUSING CRISIS WE
MUST KEEP THE SAFETY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. PUTTING OUR
FIREFIGHTERS AND FIRST
RESPONDERS FRONT AND CENTER WE
SIMPLY CANNOT CONTINUE BUSINESS
AS USUAL IN THIS SPACE. SB
TWELVE TAKES THE NECESSARY AND
HOLISTIC APPROACH NEEDED TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA BUILT SAFELY.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE STATE
FARM MARSHAL'S OFFICE TO
DEVELOP COMPREHENSIVE TIERED
WILDFIRE RISK REDUCTION
STANDARDS FOR DEVELOPMENTS IN
OUR STATE'S MOST FIRE PRONE
AREAS AS CENTER CENTER REQUIRE
ARTICULATED. THE CITY STANDARDS
WHICH WOULD BE REQUIRED TO BE
MET BEFORE LOCAL APPROVAL THE
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDE PROVISIONS
SUCH AS EMERGENCY INGRESS AND
EGRESS ROUTES. FIREBREAKS
DEFENSIBLE SPACE MAINTENANCE
AND VEGETATION MANAGEMENT WHICH
IS ALL ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL.
THIS WILL ALSO MOVES BEYOND THE
CURRENT STATE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK WHICH IS FOCUSED ON
INDIVIDUAL STRUCTURES AND LOOKS
MORE BROADLY AT THE COMMUNITY
LEVEL IMPACTS OF WILDFIRE. SB
TWELVE DOES NOT PROHIBIT LOCAL
AGENCIES FROM APPROVING NEW
DEVELOPMENT. BUT INSTEAD
REQUIRES STRINGENT YET WORKABLE
STANDARDS AND NECESSARY PART TO
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS IN OUR NEW
NORMAL OF YOUR LONG FIRE SEASON.
FINALLY THE BILL ESTABLISHES A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR JURISDICTIONS
TO HELP PAY FOR THE PLANNING
EFFORTS INCLUDED IN THE BILL.
IN CLOSING I WANT TO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND WE
STRONGLY URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
TWELVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
USE THE FINAL WILL NOW GO TO
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT WHO MIGHT BE HERE IN
THE GALLERY AND I. DON'T SEE
ANYONE THEN WE WILL LOOK TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE. THERE'S NO
ONE. I DON'T SEE ANYONE THERE.
ARE THEY LET'S MOVE TO ARE
THOSE WHO ARE ON THE PHONE
LINES WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. OF S. B. TWELVE. THE
PROPOSAL PAULINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
FIRST TIME AGO TWO IS LINE ONE
TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT
HOLLY FOR MEETING AT THE AT THE
WHITE HOUSE PUBLIC AFFAIR
CALLING IN SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF
THE TREE CARE INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION. WELCOME TO A LINE
OF. ONE THREE FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID
KING CALLING FROM UNION CITY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
ARCHIPELAGO LINE OF. ONE SIX
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
EVEN IF HE WITH THE- BUSINESS
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. AND NOBODY
THE PHONE LINES. THERE ARE NO
OTHER WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
LINE MODERATOR. WHEN SHE. I
DON'T KNOW MY LIFE DEPARTMENT
OKAY THEN LET US MOVE NOW TO
OPPOSITION AND THERE ARE TO
LEAD- WITNESSES FOR OPPOSITION
NO SILVIO FERRARI OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND ADAM RING I'M
SORRY ADAM I THINK I DIDN'T DO
YOUR LAST NAME CORRECT THE
OTHER DAY SO I'LL TRY AGAIN
WOULD REGALE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE SO WE'LL
START WITH SUN MISTER FERRARI.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- STILL BE OVERREACH IN
HERE ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
HERE IN OPPOSITION SB TWELVE
TODAY. A BILL THAT CONTINUES TO
BE IDENTIFIED BY IF YOU GET ON
THE FIRST MEDIA HOUSING KILLER.
I WANT TO START MY COMMENTS BY
JUST MAKING ABSOLUTE CERTAIN TO
EXPRESS. OUR APPRECIATION OF
THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF HAVE
SPENT A TREMENDOUS. AMOUNT OF
TIME WITH US OVER THE PAST FEW
MONTHS- NEED TO GO SHE ASIANS
STARTED REALLY LATE JANUARY-
THE CONVERSATIONS ARE HARD.
THEY'RE VERY DIFFICULT AND
THEY'RE VERY TECHNICAL
DIFFICULT IN THE SENSE BECAUSE
AS YOU'VE HEARD AND IT'S TRUE
WILD FIRES ARE GETTING WORSE WE
SEEN LIVES LOST. AND HUMANIZE
IT MAKES EVERYONE WANT TO DO
THE RIGHT THING TO PROTECT OUR
NEIGHBORS AND PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES. HAVE CONCLUDED-
DIFFICULT BECAUSE THE SOLUTION
INVOLVES. LANDERS FLAWS
SHIELDING CODES FIRE CODES FOR
THE FORESTRY CODE HOW TO
IMPLEMENT DEFENSIBLE SPACE.
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT EVEN
MODIFICATIONS THE LIST GOES ON
THIS. IS A COMPLICATED ISSUE.
AT THE HEART OF THE- WE
ABSOLUTE KNOW THAT AUTHOR. IS
AN AND RAW TO MAKE SURE THAT
DOES. ARE BUILT THE MOST BUYERS
WE POP SO DO WE ALSO KNOW THAT
OUR MEMBERS. ARE SINCERE AND
RIGHT IN THEIR EXTREME
CONCERNED THAT WE GET THIS
WRONG. IT COULD BE DEVASTATING
TO THE STATE PIPELINE OF
PROJECTS NOT ONLY THE PROJECT
AND READY TO BE BUILT. THE
PROJECT THAT REPRESENT THE
DEVELOPMENT PIPELINE THAT ARE
DECADES PLUS IN DEVELOPMENT AND
REPRESENT WHAT IS OUT THERE FOR
THE FUTURE. OUR MEMBERS BUILD
EIGHTY PLUS PERCENT OF ALL THE
HOUSING IN THE STATE. AND THEIR
PROJECTS GET DERAILED IT'S NOT
AN EXAGGERATION TO SAY THAT
THERE WILL NOT BE NEED FOR
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN THOSE PROJECTS
INCLUDE. SINGLE FAMILY MULTI
FAMILY AND AFFORDABLE PROJECTS.
WHILE ONE MAIN CONCERN
CONTINUES TO BE AROUND THE ROLE
OF PR AND THEIR INVOLVEMENT IN
THIS PROCESS. THE MORE TIME YOU
SPEND THIS BILL AND RECEIVE I
IT IS BEEN YEARS BUT- NOT FOR
WHAT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PEEL
BACK. AND EMBRACE WITH
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS IS THAT
THERE ARE ISSUES THAT STILL
REMAIN WITHIN THIS BUILDING TO
BE ADDRESSED THERE ARE
CLARIFICATIONS THAT ARE NEED TO
BE MADE THERE. ARE TERMS THAT
NEED TO BE UNDERSTOOD. YEAH BY
THAT THERE IS A- POSSIBILITY OF
GETTING TO THAT- BY ALMOST WITH
EVERY. WE KNOW WHAT THE WHOLE
DECLINE. WE ARE VERY HOPE THAT
CAN BY APPROPRIATELY PLACED
FIREBREAK THE TOP OF THAT HILL
WHERE WE CAN BE STANDING
SHOULDER TO SHOULDER. NORMALLY
ADDRESS FIRE RISK KNOWING THAT
WE'RE PROTECTING HOUSING. FOR
WE ARE OPPOSED- WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HIS TEAM- WE THANK
THIS COMMITTEE FOR THEIR TIME-
IF YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
FERRARI AND NOW WE HAVE ADAM
OUR REGULAR FROM THE- K.
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU ADAMANTLY HERE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE ALL SEVEN RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU MUCH ECHO
AND WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
STAFF AND ALL THE COMMITTEE
CONSULTANTS WEEK WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING FOR MONTHS- VERY
DIFFICULT DISCUSSIONS OVER THE
PAST FEW MONTHS. AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE WITH THE AUTHOR'S- IN
STAFF TO RESOLVE OUR
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THAT THE
CENTERS THESE AND- GET SHE AND
MUCH NEEDED AND RESPONSIBLE
ABOUT PLANNED HOUSING PROJECT
CAN STILL PROCEED. TO BE CLEAR
OUR OPPOSITION TO THE BILL IS
NOT WITH THE INTENT TO PROTECT
COMMUNITIES FROM CATASTROPHIC
WIRED WILDFIRES INCREASED FIRE
RESILIENCY STANDARDS. INDEED
ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED AGREE ON THAT PREMISE
NEW HOUSING IN THE AREA MUST BE
DEVELOPED TO THE HIGHEST BUYER
MAKING. RESILIENCY STANDARDS.
RIGHT NOT ONLY ALREADY FILLED
THE- BUT MANY K. IN COURT FIRE
RESILIENT MEASURES THANK ABOVE
AND BEYOND EIGHT LOCAL LAWS.
THAT CHAD UNDERGROUNDING LINES.
ADDITION POPPERS OWN BEYOND
STATE MINIMUM IMPROVE FORCED.
IN THE SURROUNDING AREAS.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS FIRE
STATIONS THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT BE BUILT WITHOUT THESE
PROJECTS. THE ISSUES WE HAVE
WITH THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED. WE BELIEVE ENCOURAGE
AND PROVIDE NEW LEGAL ARGUMENTS.
AND UNNECESSARY LITIGATION
REYES THE LAND USE FOR
DEVELOPER THAT WHILE TO DO THE
THING WANT TO BE A HIGH THE
STANDARDS. WHILE OUR CONCERN
ARE. NATURE THEY ARE IMPORTANT
TO BE A DRAFT. SO THAT THE LEAD.
ENSURE THAT ATHLETES THAT'S NOT
WASH MY NEEDED HOW THE THAT THE
RESPONSIBLY LARGE SWAP OF
CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA RECENTLY
SHALL THE MEDIA HOME PRICE
RECORD LAST MONTH TOPPING FOR
THE FIRST TIME SEVEN FORTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR. FIFTY HOUSING
CRISIS CONTINUES TO WORSEN
EVERY YEAR WE CONTINUE TO FALL.
OF BUILDING AND HOUSING IN
INCOME AREAS IN REMOVE LARGE
WALK IN LAND IN THE MIRACLE
ONLY FREDERICK. THIS CRISIS.
THERE IS A POPCORN THAT
APPROPRIATE BALANCE OF THAT THE
MOST FIRE RESILIENT AND WELL
PLANNED PROJECT CAN PROCEED.
WITHOUT INJECTING UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION OR FURTHER DELAY IN
STOPPING IN HOUSING PROJECTS.
HOWEVER UNTIL THESE ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS ARE TAKEN WE D BELIEVE
THE BILL INCREASES- THE HOUSING
CRISIS. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE WITH THE AUTHOR- TO
WORK TOWARDS ADDRESSING THEM
APPRECIATE FINE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION IN- GALLERY SAYING
NINE. I'LL LOOK AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE I SEE NO ONE THERE WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP ANY
OPPOSITION THAT SB TWELVE.
RIGHT OPPOSITION PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. DO YOU HAVE ONE LINE
STANDING BY. LINE NUMBER SIX
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KELLY CAPRIC WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS OUTLINING OUR CONCERNS
WITH THE PREVIOUS STATEMENTS.
ALL RIGHT AND ONE MORE WILL BE
GETTING YOUR NAME OUT THERE ONE
NUMBER IN A MOMENT. CORRECT
LINE NUMBER ONE SEVEN TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CHRIS WILSON WITH YOU NOT BY
THE COUNTY BUSINESS FEDERATION
IN OPPOSED TO SB TWELVE THANK
YOU. NOTHING MORE PREVALENT AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR IT BRING ABOUT TO THE
COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ON S. B.
TWELVE. CENTER CRITICIZING. THE
YOU SURE THE TO SUCCUMB OF IN
I'D GO ALL AND DO THIS BUT I
WANT IGNORE- YOU KNOW SOMETHING
IN PARTICULAR THAT THE
OPPOSITION- SUGGESTED THAT.
THEY'RE SEEKING ADDITIONAL
TECHNICAL CLARIFICATION
AMENDMENT. SOME REASONABLE. IN
TERMS OF WORKING THESE THINGS
OUT WITH FOLKS SO I JUST WANT
TO GET THAT ON THE RECORD THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU SENATOR-
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY SAY NAINA WANT
TO THANK- CENTER MCGUIRE FOR-
PICKING UP THIS MANTLE AS-
CENTER ALLUDED TO AT THE
BEGINNING THIS IS NOW BEEN A
THREE YEAR- JOURNEY- AND HIS ON
TO BE JUST FRANK- IT IT HAS
BEEN A CHAOTIC- JOURNEY- WITH
SOME CALM WITHIN THIS CHAMBER
BACK IN. TWO NINETEEN- AND- AND
AT TIMES- NOT THE BEST
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND ITS CD IN
THE PAST YEARS AND ACTUALLY
CENTER MCGUIRE AND I BOTH WORK
TOGETHER- WITH THE ORIGINAL
AUTHOR OF THE BILL- TO TRY TO
GET SOME OF THE OTHER AND I
THINK WE DID THAT AND BILLS
VETED AND- BUT THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE IN CYPRUS AT
THE CENTER. BOB PICKING IT- AND
ALSO I THANK YOU FOR WITH US
THE AMOUNT SO YOU ACCEPT TO
THAT THIS IS ABOUT VERY HIGH
SEVERITY WILDFIRE ZONES- AND
ABOUT THE TWENTY FIFTEEN OPR
REGULATIONS I WILL SAY THAT I-
I'VE EXPRESSED THIS TOBY ARE
DIRECTLY BUT I THINK- OPR IS A-
INTO A- AREAS ITS MOST.
GUIDANCE BY GOING HIGH WILDFIRE
HI SIR AREA AND THEN THE- ALL
OF US OR A BECAUSE- I SOME
POINT YOU END UP COVERING. AS A.
WHAT THEN MAYBE IT'S POINT EVEN.
OF AND- YOU I'M USUALLY VERY
ALIGNED OPR IN TERMS OF SUSTAIN
LAND. POLICY AND WE THE FIGHT
MARSHAL AND SOMETIME. OF THE
FARMERS VERY FOR. ON ON FIRE
SAFETY NOT MISS OF NOT SPOKE.
ON THEIR ROLE- AROUND HOUSING.
FOR THEN WE SAW LOOKING AT THIS
AND IN FACT- THEN WE START.
RESTRICTING RESTRICT- AND-
SOMETHING WE MAY OUR HOUSING
CRISIS- EVEN WORSE THERE'S A-
WHY ALMOST HALF OF. HOUSING AND
LAST THREE YEARS IS BEEN BILL.
AND WHAT WE AND OUR HIGH RISK
AREAS. THE REASON IS THAT WE IT
SO DARN HARD. TODAY HOUSING AND
THE- WILDFIRE AREA WHETHER THAT
IS SAN FRANCISCO OR SAN RAFAEL
OR- BURLINGAME OR LOS ANGELES
OR WHEREVER ELSE. ON IT'S NOT A
GOOD ENOUGH FOR US TO RESTRICT
IN THE WILD FIRE AREAS AND WE
ALL WANT TO RELIEVE. PRESSURE
ON THE WELFARE IS NOT GOOD
ENOUGH TO RESTRICT IN THOSE
AREAS WITHOUT SAYING WHERE WE
ARE GOING TO BUILD IT THE
DRAMATICALLY MORE HOUSING THAT
WE NEED IN CALIFORNIA. AND WHAT
I APPRECIATE ABOUT CENTER
MCGUIRE IS HE'S- NOT JUST
SAYING LET'S RESTRICT SEVERAL
WIRES ALSO BEEN A KEY PARTNER.
IN EFFORTS TO EXPAND HOUSING
AND OTHER AREAS- AND SO YOU'RE
TAKING A BROAD- VIEW AND I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THAT- AND SO- I
KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO WORK- WITH THE OPPOSITION-
TO SAY HEY WE WANT TO. REDUCE
PRESSURE IN THESE AREAS BUT
KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE CAN BE
DEVELOPMENT IF IT'S DONE IN A
SAFE WAY- AND I THINK THIS BILL
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO REALLY BE
A POSITIVE. CONNOTATION AND SO
I'M RECOMMENDING AN AYE VOTE-
WITH THE AMENDMENT- SO WITH AS-
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU SOME
AND MISTER CHAIRMAN AGAIN- NOT
JUST WORDS FOR I'M SINCERELY.
FOR IN- IN TWO DEPRECIATE
LEADERSHIP SIR THANK YOU CENTER.
WELL FOR YOUR. I WAS A HIT
WHERE CHAIR WAS JUST TALKING.
THAT THIS SENATE. BODY HAS BEEN
IN THE SOME OF THE MORE PER.
PEACE OF HOUSING THE- OVER THE
PAST MANY YEARS. ISSUE ALONE.
HI THE SENATE PER TEM IS PRETTY
HOUSING PACKAGE. FOCUS ON A-
JUDICIAL REVIEW. FORCE LOS WHEN
A TO HOUSE. TO YOU HAVE CENTER
COPIER. WHO IS THE- COMMONSENSE
LET THAT WOULD FOR TO. OF HOUSE
ON AND DYING MALLS OFFICE. IN
MINISTER FORM. FAIR WINNERS
ADVANCE. CRITICAL BILLTHAT
WOULD ALLOW FOR ME. DEVELOPMENT
OF TEN WERE IT'S MARK PLACE OR-
INFILL OR WHERE PROTEIN ADAM TO
DO PLAY IN UP TO FOUR PLEXUS.
FOR NEIGHBORHOOD DEVELOP. WE
HAVE TO BE FOCUS ON TO THIS
CRISIS THAT MEANS CAN TO. A IN
STATE. IN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IS GOING TO LITIGATE M. O. R.
DEVELOPER BEING BUILT IN THIS.
GOOD THEY ARE NOT BEING BUILT
FIRE SAFE. WE CAN FIX THAT. IT
IS A BALANCE THIS IS AND
DIFFICULT BILL THE TECHNICAL
SIDE BUT ONCE A DAY YOU IN PART
TO ME FOR OUR FOR HIS. UP FROM
C. V. I. A. N. A ALSO IT HERE
NOT KEEP SAYING DAY WE'RE GOING
TO ENGAGE FOR GOING TO CAN TO
GET INTO WEEDS AT THE TO WORK
ISSUE. THIS IS A LIVE IN A OF
OR IN THE STATE WHEN IT COMES
HOW WE DID AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE IN A THANK YOU
FOR THE TIME HE MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU SENATOR-
THE RIVER MOTION ON SBA
EXHIBITS THE TWELFTH. CENTER IS
OUR MOTION MAKER OF THE- AND
WITHOUT MATTER BECAUSE- WOULD
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THIS
IS BILL TWELVE BUCKS MARK THE
IS PASS AS A MAN BUT FOR
AMENDED IN RE REFER TO THE CA
ON A PER. SENATOR WIENER I
WIENER AYE BATES. BATES NO
COPYRIGHT HI CABALLERO CORTES.
COURTESY AM GOING. BY. WILL BE
BY CENTER CORTESE- WE'LL START
OFF WITH ITEMS HAND SB. SEVEN
EIGHTY. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
AND MEMBERS- COLLEAGUES SOME
PLEASED TO PRESENT SB SEVEN
EIGHTY A BILL THAT IMPLEMENTS
CHANGES TO BOTH ENHANCE
INRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS KNOWN AS EASY I D.'S.
IN COMMUNITY VOCALIZATION
INVESTMENT AUTHORITIES C. R. I.
A.'S- THOSE LAWS ARE IN PLACE
TO HELP CITIES AND COUNTIES USE
THESE TOOLS TO FINANCE LOCAL
DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS SINCE THE
ELIMINATION OF REDEVELOPMENT
AGENCIES IN TWENTY ELEVEN THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED SEVERAL TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING TOOLS TO
SUPPORT INFRASTRUCTURE. IN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING CRISIS
HE I HAVE DECENT C. R. I. A.'S
SUBMERGES TOOLS THAT ALLOW
LOCAL AGENCIES TO USE A TAX
INCREMENT OF PARTICIPATING
ENTITIES THE PHONE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECTS. HOWEVER THE
MINIMAL UPTAKE OF BOTH THE- OF
DECENCY ARE ACES PROVEN THAT
THEY'RE OVERLY CUMBERSOME. TO
ESTABLISH AND OPERATE. WITH A
HOUSING RATHER CITIES AND
COUNTIES ACROSS THE STATE THE
REVITALIZATION OF THESE TOOLS
IS WELL OVERDUE. SB SEVEN
EIGHTY MAKE SEVERAL CHANGES. I
TO III OF TNC ARE A LAW THAT
WILL ENABLE LOCAL AGENCIES TO
USE THESE TOOLS TO EFFECTIVELY
STIMULATE DEVELOPMENT IN THEIR
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. AMONG OTHER
IMPORTANT CHANGES THE BILL
STREAMLINES THE PROCESS FOR
AMENDING EXISTING PLANS AND
REWRITES THE TEN YEAR PROTEST
PROCESS IN C. R. A. LAW. TO
MAKE C. R. I. A.'S IN E. AYE IF
THESE MORE VIABLE FOR LOCAL
AGENCIES TO CORRECT CREATE AND
OPERATE. ONE THING OF THE- AND
COMMITTEE CONSOLES FOR WORKING
WITH US EXTENSIVELY ON THIS
BILL- THERE IS A TECHNICAL
AMENDMENT- OR AN AMENDMENT- I
BELIEVE. YES THAT'S CORRECT IN
THE SECTION NINE OF THE
ANALYSIS- I WON'T GET INTO THE
DETAIL OF THAT BUT IT IS THERE
IN THE ANALYSIS- HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF- BOX SO
HOLDEN FROM CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT ALSO KNOWN AS CAL
IT YEAH MICHAEL LANE FROM SPUR
AND I SHOULD MENTION THE DEN
CARE ACT FROM KHALLID- IS ON
THE LINE- NOT TO TESTIFY BUT
AVAILABLE FOR TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS I'M THANK YOU A
SECURE- AND COLLEAGUES- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW GO
TO THE- WITNESSES IN FAVOR OF.
SB SEVEN EIGHTY. THAT'S OF-
ZACKS ARE CORRECT SILVA AND
THEN MICHAEL LANE. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
SENATORS MISTER CLARK CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK. THIS YES. YES GREAT
THANK YOU MY NAME IS GO BACK TO
THE HOTEL AND I SERVICE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
LOCAL ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
HOWEVER REPRESENTS OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED LOCAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPERS AND STAKEHOLDERS.
TELEGRAM PROFESSIONALS THAT ARE
HELPING BUSINESSES THRIVE
GROWING LOCAL ECONOMIES AND
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR
CALIFORNIANS OUR MEMBERS
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE AND THE
BENEFIT THE TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING CAN BRING TO LOCAL
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING
HELPING SUPPORT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING SOLUTIONS AS WELL AS
BUILDING AND REPAIRING
INFRASTRUCTURE MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE EXPLORING USING
EFT FOR ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
ESPECIALLY AS WE LOOK AT
ECONOMIC RECOVERY AND OTHERS
ARE CONSIDERING CREE AS WHICH
HAVE A SPECIFIC FOCUS ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. LAST FALL
COUNTY CONVENED A WORKING GROUP
OF ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
PRACTITIONERS TO REVIEW THE
EXISTING TAX INCREMENT
FINANCING TOOL AND THEY'RE
SUGGESTED IMPROVEMENTS TO MAKE
THESE TOOLS MORE WORKABLE ARE
CONTAINED IN SB SEVEN EIGHTY
AND COMMITTEE STAFF OF THE HELP
OF THE SPECIFICS IN THE
ANALYSIS WAS WELL WE APPRECIATE
SENATOR CORTESE AND HIS STAFF
ARE WORKING WITH TALENT ON
THESE ISSUES AND WE ALSO THINK
THAT COMMITTEE STAFFER THEIR
DETAILED REVIEW. INCLUDING
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR SB. SEVEN EIGHTY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
LET'S LANE. EACH MEDICARE
NUMBERS IN THE CAMPUS BAY AREA
OR RESEARCH. A PUBLIC POWER
THINK TANK NOT FOR. THE
DISSOLUTION REDEVELOP AGENCIES
IN TWENTY ALL OF THIS SPENT THE
PAST DECADE WORKING ON
REPLACEMENT TOOLS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT CAN ALLOW FOR
BROWNFIELD REMEDIATION
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT IN
UPGRADES ASSEMBLAGE OF PARCELS
AND PRODUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. WE HAVE WORKED ON THE
ISPS CREE AS NIFTY THAT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AUTHORITIES
IN ORDER TO RECREATE AT LEAST
SOME OF THE EFFICACY OF TAX
INCREMENT FINANCING PREVIOUSLY
AVAILABLE UNDER REDEVELOPMENT.
A WHILE I AM WHERE AWARE OF
DOZENS OF JURISDICTIONS THAT
TAKING A HARD LOOK AT SENATE
DISTRICTS USING THESE NEW TECH
TOOLS. ONLY A HANDFUL OF
ACTUALLY FOLLOW THROUGH THAT'S
UNDERGOING NEED TO LISTEN TO
THE LOCAL TO CONTINUE TO
IMPROVE AND PERFECT THESE
TOOLS. SB SEVEN ANY WILL MAKE
THE IDF FEED AND CREUS MORE
USER FRIENDLY. AND THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT IS NEEDED NOW TO
ALLOW THESE TOOLS TO BE ADOPTED.
MORE WIDELY HERE'S MY VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. OKAY IS
THERE ANYONE IN THE SENATE
GALLERY- FAVOR- SB SEVEN EIGHTY
SAYING NON WILL GO TO ROOM ONE
TWELVE SAYING NOW WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES WITH A
MODERATOR PLEASE TO UP
SUPPORTERS OF SB. SEVEN EIGHTY.
THE STATE'S SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY THERE ON YOUR PHONE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE OF THEM ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'LL GO FIRST TO LINE.
ONE SEVENTY FIVE. REMEMBER LAKE
ROAD LOBBY HAPPILY IN
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. WE HAVE LINE. ONE
SEVEN SIX ONE SEVENTY SIX. YOUR
LINE IS OPEN ONE SEVEN SIX.
FROM JULY AND. ONE FORTY ONE
ONE FOUR ONE. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ROD DRURY FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON HERE TO
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN EIGHTY. HI
WELCOME BACK TO ONE SEVENTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HIBERNICA
DELIVERS CREWS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FLORIDA ACTION FUND
AND SUPPORT. NO FOR THE
NINETEEN Q. THANK YOU ERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHEN I GOT
OFF POSITION TO SB SEVEN
EIGHTY- WE HAVE NO LEAD
OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED AS OR
ANYONE IN THE GALLERY IN
OPPOSITION C. NINE WILL GO TO
ROOM ONE TWELVE SAYING NO ONE
THERE GO T THE PHONE LINES
PLEASE QUEUE UP. OPPONENTS TO
SB SEVEN EIGHTY. THANK YOU TO
STATE OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. STEP ONE AND THEN ZERO
PLEASE. THERE ARE NO LINES INTO
AT THIS TIME OKAY WORRY ABOUT
THE COMMITTEE CALLING SEND
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CASING
NINETEEN OF EMOTION. THE BALLOT
MEASURE BY CENTER CABALLERO-
AND- SENATE HAS THE I THINK YOU
DID ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT IN
YOUR OPENING YES A MINUTE YES
RESEARCHER- COMMITTEE ON SEPT-
THE COMMITTEE'S AMENDMENT- IF I
MAY CLOSE I JUST WANT TO- THANK
AGAIN THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE. I THANK THE BILL'S
SPONSORS FOR ALL THEIR HARD
WORK- EARLY ON- THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS- WORKED
WITH US CLOSELY- TO MAKE SOME
PRIOR MODIFICATIONS TO THE
BILL. I'M PROUD TO SAY THERE'S
NO OPPOSITION ON RECORD I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
GREAT THANK YOU MADAM
CONSULTING CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THIS IS SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY BY SENATOR CORTEZ
SEE IF THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED SENATOR WIENER HI
WIENER AYE BATES YOU KNOW
PUTTING. IT'S NOT VOTING
CABALLERO HI CABALLERO
COURTESY. PHOTO COURTESY IOMEGA.
WELL CHORE BOOK HI THE CHOPPER
I'D SKINNER- HI NUMBER I WOOD
COUNTY. FIVE ZERO. I'M SORRY
HAS ENOUGH VOTES WILL ON CALL
FOR ABSENT AS CENTER HE WILL
ARE TO A ALIVE S. B. NINETY
ONE. THANK YOU MR SURE I. AM
VERY PLEASED TO PRESENT THE SB
SEVEN NINETY ONE WHICH CREATES
A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE UNIT
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE THE CONSTRUCTION OF
SURPLUS LAND LOCAL PUBLIC
AGENCIES CONTROL THOUSANDS OF
SURPLUS SITES- THAT HAVE IN
MANY CASES THE SERVE BACON FOR
YEARS TO THE NUMEROUS PAIRS OF
LOCAL IS HE'S FACING GETTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BILL. SUCH
AS LACK OF CAPACITY IN
FINANCING EXPERTISE THE PAST
FEW YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
ADMINISTRATION OF SET THE
GROUNDWORK FOR UTILIZING UNUSED
PUBLIC LAND TO PROMOTE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
FOR EXAMPLE. GOVERNOR NEWSOM'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER IN TWENTY
NINETEEN CREATED A SMALL TEAM
OF STAFF TO FACILITATE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON APPROPRIATE STATE
OWNED ACCESS LAND. ADDITIONALLY
RECENT PASS LEGISLATION
REQUIRES EACH CITY AND COUNTY
TO REPORT TO H. C. D. AN
INVENTORY OF A SURPLUS LANDS OF
BY THIS MONTH. SINCE THESE
MEASURES HAVE BEEN IN PLACE HCD
HAS BEEN OVERWHELMED WITH CALLS
FROM LOCAL AGENCIES ASKING FOR
ASSISTANCE IN DISPOSING OF THE
SURPLUS LAND. THE INFORMATIONAL
LOCALS SITES COMING THIS MONTH
A WILL ONLY INCREASE OUR
WORKLOAD. THE STATE MUST TAKE A
MORE ACTIVE ROLE IN PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE TO LOCAL AGENCIES
AND GETTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
BILLS. ON LOCAL SURPLUS LAND.
SB SEVEN NINETY ONE ACHIEVES
THIS BY CREATING A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE UNIT WITHIN EIGHT C.
D. BILL FACILITY THE
DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION
AFFORDABLE HOUSING UNIT WILL
PROVIDE ADVICE TECHNICAL AND
FINANCING ASSISTANCE AND IN AND
OUT. CONSULTING SERVICES TO
LOCAL AGENCIES WITH SURPLUS
LAND AND DEVELOPERS THAT SEEKS
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON
THOSE SITES AS WELL. THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES A UNIT TO SUBMIT
A ROBUST ANNUAL REPORT THAT
WILL PROVIDE DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION AND A BREAKDOWN OF
FUNDING SOURCES FOR ASSISTED
HOUSING UNITS. SB SEVEN NINETY
ONE HAS THE ENDORSEMENT OF THE
SENATE HOUSING PRODUCTION WORK
GROUP WILL SERVEAS A NEXT STEP
FOR INCREASING HOUSING
PRODUCTION ON UNUSED PUBLIC
LANDS. I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEE CONSOLES
FOR THE DILIGENT WORK IN
GETTING THIS BILL READY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. OF IT TRULY
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN READY-
WITHOUT THE SIGNIFICANT. HEALTH
OF THIS COMMITTEE. BUT HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT TO MARK IS
MARK STIVERS FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP.
AGAIN THANK YOU- AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. FIVE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MR STIVERS WHO'S HERE WITH OF
THE WITNESS YOU MAY BE SEATED.
THANK YOU MARCH DIVERSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING PARTNERSHIP-
WE ARE PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB
SEVEN NINETY ONE TO FACILITATE
THE CONSTRUCTION OF A WHOLE
FORMAL HOUSING. ON SURPLUS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT LAND LOOK
GOVERNMENTS POSSESS NUMEROUS
PARCELS OF LAND THAT ARE NOT
NEEDED FOR PUBLIC PURPOSES AND
ARE ELIGIBLE TO BECOME. TO BE
DECLARED SURPLUS. CALIFORNIA
SURPLUS LANDS ACTORS PRIORITY
TO DEVELOPMENT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ON THESE PARCELS. MANY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HOWEVER HAVE
MINIMAL CAPACITY OR EXPERTISE
TO ISSUE AND EVALUATE REQUESTS
FOR PROPOSALS OR NEGOTIATE SALE
OR LEASE AGREEMENTS WITH
DEVELOPERS. AS A RESULT OF ITS
CURRENT WORK ON GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S ACCESS SITE EXECUTIVE
ORDER. THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING CARRYING DEVELOPMENT
CITY NOW HAS THIS EXPERTISE. SB
SEVEN NINETY ONE SHARES THE
STATE'S EXPERTISE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO FACILITATE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF MUCH NEEDED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING ON SURPLUS
LOCAL. PROPERTIES WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE GALLERY
THING NINE- ROOM. ONE TWELVE.
NO ONE THERE WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES PLEASE QUEUE UP
SUPPORT FOR SB SEVEN NINETY
ONE. THE STATE SUPPORT FOR THIS
BILL YOU MAY PRESS ONE BEEN
THERE ON YOUR PHONE AGAIN
THAT'S A ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
PLEASE. ALTHOUGH CRYSTALLINE
SIXTY TWO SIX TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. THE ONLY GATHERED FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT. MAKING
SURE TO HAVE ONE OF THE
LEARNING QUEUE WITH ME JUST A
MOMENT. WE ALSO HAVE A LINE.
ONE THIRTY THREE ONE THREE
THREE. WILL MOVE ON THE LINE
ONE SEVEN SEVEN. I COULD
AFTERNOON SURE WINNER DIFFICULT
BACKGROUND WITH THE NONPROFIT
HAPPENS OCCASIONALLY CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE NOT YET UNTIL NON PUSH
FOR SUPPORT THAT AND WE TRY TO
EDUCATE OUR HAVE TO SUPPORT
THANK THANK YOU SO MUCH. THERE
ARE NO OTHER LINES IN Q. RIGHT
WE WILL- NO GOOD OPPOSITION WE
KNOW LEAD OPPONENT IS OR ANYONE
OPPOSITION IN THE GALLERY-
SEEING NINE IS THERE ANYONE A
ROOM ONE TWELVE OPPOSITION
SAYING NINE. OF WILL GO TO THE
PHONE LINES TO BE PLEASED TO UP
ANY OPPOSITION TO SB SEVEN
NINETY ONE. THE STATE
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE AGAIN
THAT'S ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
PLEASE. WE DO HAVE ONE LINE IN
Q. ONE MOMENT. THAT COMMENT
COMES FROM LINE ONE SIXTY SIX
ONE OF THE OPEN. THANK YOU BOB
MODERATOR MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN SMITH
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. IN OPPOSITION-
TO THE BILL TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT WOULD LEAD TO CONSTRUCTION
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING WITHOUT
KEEPING THE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS IN MIND WE ARE
CONCERNED- WE ARE CLOSED TODAY
THANK YOU. TURN ON THE OTHER
LINES IN Q. GREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ME ABOUT THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS COLLEAGUES. SEEING
NINE DOING THE MOTION. I DID.
THE MOTION BY SEN I WANTED TO
ASK A QUESTION I'M SORRY I'M
SORRY I'M I'M CURIOUS IN TERMS
OF THE CURRENT PRIORITY THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE FOR ON
THEIR SURPLUS LAND DOES INCLUDE
PARK AND RECREATION- PARK
RECREATION OPEN SPACE AND I'M
THINKING WITH A LOT OF THE
IRVINE INFILL ARE HAVING THE
URBAN PARKS FOR EXAMPLE WOULD
SEEM TO ME TO BE SOMETHING VERY
VERY IMPORTANT AND NOT TO BE
SAAS. A SUBORDINATE. MORE ON
MULTI FAMILY ON HOUSING AND IT.
I AM CONCERNED THAT THIS WOULD
NOT ALLOW THAT DISCUSSION FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHEN THEY'RE
LOOKING AT SOME OF THE SURPLUS
PROPERTY BOB FRANKLY THAT
NINETY FIVE COME ABOUT BECAUSE
OF THE PANDEMIC AND ALL THE
INABILITY TO SUSTAIN SOME OF
THE AREAS ESPECIALLY LOOK THE
COMMERCIAL AREAS THAT HAVE GONE
ON A KIND OF DORMANT. THEY MAY
BE SENATOR CORTEZ HE CAN
ADDRESS THAT CONVERT IT IS
TRULY A- SIGNIFICANT CONCERN IN
SOME OF THE NORTH ORANGE
COUNTY. URBAN AREAS WHICH DON'T
HAVE PARKS AND DON'T HAVE THAT-
YOU KNOW SAFE ACCESS TO SCHOOLS
THAT FEDERAL THAT FROM OF THE
DEVELOPMENT NEEDS TO BE VERY.
CONCERNED ABOUT AND VERY
ACCOMMODATING I'VE- GO AHEAD A
GREAT QUESTION THANK YOU FOR
ASKING IT TO ALLOW ME TO
CLARIFY SO THE BILL IS- A
VOLUNTARY- WOULD CREATE A
VOLUNTARY RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN-
ANY LOCAL. AGENCY OR
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY- SEEKING
ASSISTANCE FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PRODUCTION ON THEIR
SURPLUS LAND OR LAND THEY WOULD
EXPECT TO DECLARE SURPLUS.
WITHOUT IMPOSING ANY
REQUIREMENT- THERE'S NOTHING IN
THE BILL THAT IMPOSES ANY
REQUIREMENTS AS TO HOW THE USER
SURPLUS LAND- SO THEY WOULD
ACTUALLY MAKE THE DECISION
BEFORE CONTACTING THE STATE-
THAT THEY HAD DESIGNS ON
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
PERHAPS YOU KNOW THROW UP THEIR
HANDS SO TO SOME DEGREE AND SAY
BUT WE DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO IT.
AT WHICH POINT THEY MAKE THE
CALL- AND WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
MAKE SURE WHEN THEY MAKE THAT
CALL- THEY REALLY GET HE HELP
THAT THEY NEED WE HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO HELP THEM. BUT WE
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE- A PIECE OF
PROPERTY THAT'S LONG BEEN TO
COURT SURPLUS ON A LIGHT RAIL
LINE AND MY DISTRICT- I'M SURE
THERE'S MANY SUCH SITUATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WERE HIGH
DENSITY RESIDENTIAL FOR MORE
RESIDENTIAL WOULD BE ALLOWED BY
GENERAL PLAN- BUT IT'S OWNED.
BY A LOCAL AGENCY THAT- ISN'T
FAMILIAR WITH DEVELOPING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THEY ALSO
HAPPEN TO BE ADJACENT TO A
MAJOR REGIONAL PARKS SO THEY
CAN MAKE THE DECISION. THAT ALL
THAT GOES TO PARK. ALL THE
GIRLS WERE FOR HOUSING OR SOME
GOES TO BOTH. OR MAYBE THE
SHIFT GEARS ENTIRELY DECIDED TO
BUILD A SHOPPING CENTER OR
SOMETHING ON THAT SITE- THIS
BILL JUST SAYS IF YOU CHOOSE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- WE'RE HERE
TO HELP YOU- IT BUT- NO MANDATE
THAT YOU ACTUALLY MAKE THAT
CHOICE. IS NOT A MANDATE AND I.
A HOPE THAT IT HELPS ANSWER THE
QUESTION. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY CAN I HAVE-
THREE OF A MOTION ON SB SEVEN
NINETY ONE. PERHAPS BY SENATOR
CONWAY ARE OR ON BURKE. MOTIONS
BY CENTER ON BURKE. OKAY CENTER
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND JUST TO CLARIFY- I
THINK- I TRY TO THINK
EXTENSIVELY- COMMITTEE STUFF
FOR MR SURE YOUR STUFF HERE ON
THE COMMITTEE FOR THE SISTINE
THOUGH OPPORTUNITY SINGLE OUT
AARON THIS BILL WAS ORIGINALLY-
AS THE ORIGINAL ARE AND THE
RESULT DRAFTING OF THE BILL-
HAD AN EMPHASIS ON FUNDING AND
OBVIOUSLY WE'RE STATE FUNDING.
WOULD BE INVOLVED- THERE'S A
WHOLE BUNCH OF OTHER THINGS WE
LIKELY WILL BE INCLUDED IN THE
BILL IN TERMS OF WORKFORCE%
PROTECTIONS ETCETERA- WE TOOK
THE FUNDING. OF LANGUAGE OUT OF
THE BILL AND THE BILL IS SIMPLY
A TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE BILL AT
THIS POINT I JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY THAT FOR THE RECORD I
WASN'T. ENTIRELY SURE- ON THE
OPPOSITION LINE WHAT I WAS
HEARING BUT I WANTED TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THAT THAT
SPOKESPERSON UNDERSTOOD THAT
THE BILL WAS A TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE BILL NOW- IT DOESN'T
REALLY HAVE. A PLACE TO PUT-
FUNDING WORKFORCE- PROTECTIONS
OR THOSE KINDS OF THINGS IN IT-
AT THIS POINT ALTHOUGH-
CLEARLY- AT ONE TIME AN EARLIER
VERSION OF THE BILL DID SO.
AGAIN FOR THE RECORD- THAT
SHOULD BE A NON ISSUE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR. YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR ARE WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND MATTER CONSULTANCY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE SENATE BILL
SEVEN NINETY ONE BY SENATOR
CORTEZ THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION SENATOR WIENER AYE
WIENER AYE BATES. AYE BATES AYE
CABALLERO HI COPYRIGHT
COURTESY. CURTIS HE AYE
MCGUIRE. A CHORE BOOK. SKINNER
NUMBER HI NUMBER FIVE WITH
CASKEY. FIVE ZERO THAT HAS BEEN
A VOCAL CURRENT CALL FOR UP TO
MEMBERS- BEFORE WE GO TO LESS
BILL- IF FIVE- HOUSING
COMMITTEE SEPARATIST ALERT
ABSENT MEMBERS THAT WE ARE ON
OUR LAST BILL AND THEY SHOULD
AT SOME POINT SOON MAKE THEIR
WAY ON TO THE LIFTING F THE
CALLS- FOR ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
THAT IS MY BILL IS BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT I'M GONNA- AND
THE PROVERBIAL OF THE- CARE
GAVEL. OVER TO OUR VICE CHAIR.
SENATOR BATES. AND YOU ARE
READY SENATOR WIFE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MADAM OR SIR I'M
CALLING. SENATE BILL FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT- IS A FAIRLY
TECHNICAL- BILL AND WHAT IT
DOES IS IT MAKES MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN A CITY HAS OWNED. FOR
SMALL ZONE LOCALLY FOR SMALL
MULTI UNIT THREE TO TEN UNIT
BUILDINGS- THAT PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO BUILD THOSE
BUILDINGS- I WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR THIS BILL HAS NO
APPLICATION. AREAS THAT ARE
ZONED FOR SINGLE FAMILY HOMES-
NOT EVEN FOR DUPLEXES THE BILL
ONLY APPLIES. IF THE CITY HAS
DETERMINED LOCALLY. TO DO
ZONING TO ALLOW- BUILDINGS
BETWEEN THREE AND TEN UNITS-
AND THE WHITE HOT WHAT IS
HAPPENING NOW IN A NUMBER OF
CITIES. IS THE CITY WILL ZONE
THROUGH ITS PLANNING CODE OR
GENERAL PLAN FOR SMALL MULTI
UNIT THREE FOUR SIX EIGHT TEN-
AND THEN AT THE SAME TIME.
IMPOSE HARSH SQUARE FOOTAGE
REQUIREMENTS KNOWN AS F. A. R.
FLOOR AREA RATIO. THAT MAKE IT
EFFECTIVELY IMPOSSIBLE. TO
BUILD TO THAT ZONING. SO
EXAMPLE IF A CITY ZONES. AN
AREA LOCALLY AT FOUR UNITS TO
SAY YOU CAN BUILD A FOUR UNIT
BUILDING- ON THIS PARCEL AND
THEN IT DOES NOT SAY IT'S A
THREE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT LIVE
AND THE CITY AT THE SAME TIME
IMPOSES A VERY HARSH POINT
THREE F. A. R. WHAT THAT MEANS
IS THAT THE TOTAL SQUARE
FOOTAGE OF THAT BUILDING. WOULD
BE LIMITED TO NINE HUNDRED
SQUARE FEET WHEN YOU DIVIDE
THAT BY FOUR THAT'S TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY FIVE SQUARE FEET.
PER UNIT NO ONE IS GOING TO
BUILD THAT- AND IN FACT I
BELIEVE THAT IS- IT MIGHT NOT
ACTUALLY EVEN BE LEGAL IN TERMS
OF THE SIZE OF THE UNIT BEING
SO SMALL BUT IT'S CERTAINLY NOT
GOING TO GET BUILT AND SO
EFFECTIVELY THAT IS THE CITY.
HAVING BASICALLY FAKE ZONING
THE SALE ON PAPER REZONING FOR
FOUR UNITS OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE BUT BECAUSE OF THESE
OTHER SQUARE FOOTAGE ARBITRARY
REQUIREMENTS IT'S ACTUALLY
IMPOSSIBLE FOR YOU TO BUILD
ABOUT ZONING- THAT IS BAD
GOVERNMENT- AND WHAT THIS BILL
DOES IS IT SAYS TO CITIES ONCE
YOU HAVE VOLUNTARILY LOCALLY
ZONED FOR SMALL MULTI UNIT. YOU
CAN NOT IMPOSE OTHER
RESTRICTIONS THAT EFFECTIVELY
GIVE WITH ONE HAND AND TAKE
WITH THE OTHER IT HOSTIN
DESIGNING HAS TO MEAN SOMETHING
WANT TO BE CLEAR DOESN'T APPLY
TO SINGLE FAMILY THIS BILL DOES
NOT CHANGE OUR ZONING THIS ONLY
APPLIES TO THE CITY GETS A SET
ITS OWN LOCAL ZONING IN THIS
BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE NUMBER
BILL UNITS YOU'RE ALLOWED TO
BILLS THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
THE HEIGHT. LIMIT THAT'S A
LOCAL IT DOESN'T CHANGE
SETBACKS DOESN'T CHANGE DESIGN
STANDARDS AND I GOT A DOESN'T
EVEN APPLY IN AREAS THAT ARE
ZONED. SINGLE FAMILY. THE
ANSWER WHAT IT DOES IS IF YOU
HAVE OWN LOCAL. BETWEEN AND SO
YEAR- THE APP ARE WILL BE ONE
POINT OH AND I WANT TO KNOW.
THAT ONCE THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO RECENTLY ZONED ITS
ENTIRE CITY FOR FOUR UNITS FOR
CLOCKS- SACRAMENTO UPDATED ITS
FLOOR AREA RATIO TO BE ONE
POINT NO. BECAUSE IT'S LOWER
FLOOR AREA RATIO THAT HAD
EXISTED WOULD HAVE MADE IT
IMPOSSIBLE TO ACTUALLY BUILD.
FOUR PLEXUS- AND SEVERED WHAT
WE'RE DOINGIS IN LINE WITH
WHAT- YOU KNOW OTHER CITIES OF
DOMINICK DUNNE THIS
VOLUNTARILY- AND THEN FOR
BUILDINGS THAT ARE EIGHT TO TEN
UNIT C. F. A. R. WOULD BE ONE
POINT TWO. FIVE SO THIS WILL
SIMPLY ENABLE PEOPLE TO BUILD.
TO THE DENSITY THAT THE CITY
HAS DETERMINED IT WANTS LOCALLY
THE OTHER PIECE OF THE BILL-
HAS TO DO WITH A PARCEL SIZES
THAT IF. CITIES HAVE MINIMUM
LOT SIZES BUT IF YOU HAVE A
NONCONFORMING LOT SIZE SAYS A
PRE EXISTED- THEM THE CITY'S
MODERN ZONING- THAT THE CITY
COULD NOT USE THAT AS A BASIS
TO THE NIGHT- PROJECT. ON SO
COLLEAGUES THIS IS
FUNDAMENTALLY A GOOD
GOVERNMENT- LAW THAT RESPECTS
AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF LOCAL
CONTROL- BUT IS SIMPLY
REQUIRING CITIES TO DO WHAT
THEY SAY- THEY SUPPOSEDLY-
DOING AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
OUR FOREIGN RIVALS WHO ARE WITH
ME TODAY TESTIFIED- ARE LUIS
MERON TODAY FROM CALIFORNIA
YIMBY. AND MICHAEL. LANE FROM
SPUR. THANK YOU SAID. THAT ARE
YOU CALL HE LEAVES WITH.
MODERATOR PLEASE CALL THEM.
THEY'RE OPEN. GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS MY NAME IS LOUIS BRONTE
I WOULD CALIFORNIA BE THAT
SPONSOR AT THE COURTS AND THE
EIGHT I FIRST WANT TO THANK
CENTER MCGUIRE IN THE
GOVERNMENT AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR FOCUS
ATTENTION TO DETAIL BOB AND
GAUGE MEANT NUMBERS TO
SPENDING- A GOOD TIME WITH THAT
ON THE BILL WHEN IT WITHIN.
THEIR COMMITTEE- AND CENTER
MENTION THE COR OF BEEPER
SEVENTY IS THERE A- OF OUR
COMMITMENT RESOLVING CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT. BY MILLION FROM.
TOOLBOX THAT MANY. PROMINENTLY
AMONG THEM. ADMITTING THAT HOW.
RESEARCH FROM THE UC BERKELEY
TURNER ST FIND LOW PERMISSIVE
AT THEY ARE. AND HIGHWAY. OF.
THE COST OF HOUSING FOR MISSING
HOUSING WHICH OFTEN NOT PROP
ENOUGH. TO HIRE BIG WHILE. IS
THAT IMPORTANT TO SURE THAT ARE
IN MIDDLE OUTSIDE ARE BESIDE.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT
MIDDLE- DONATES TRIPLE WHEN IT
SAYS THAT MIDDLE. IS R. BECAUSE
HOUSING RATHER AND ALLOW IN A
PART PLACE. AT CENTER WIENER.
THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
OWNING SINGLE MULTI PLANNING IT
JUST TAKES SHARED THAT'S NOT A
IS TRIPLE. I THINK. PEOPLE JOBS
THE BILL HAPPY ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MIGHT HAVE WITH IT- WITH
THAT I ENCOURAGE YOUR SUPPORT
BUT BEFORE. SOMEBODY THANK YOU.
CAN'T MISTER LANE BETTER VICE
CHAIR AND THE BALLOT BY MEMBERS
MIKE THE CAMPUS VERY FUNNY
URBAN REESE IS A- PUBLIC
QUALITY THANKS HONEST THAT FOUR
SEVEN EIGHT EASILY BE CALLED
THE TRUTH AND ZONING ACT
BECAUSE IT WILL REQUIRE THE
WHAT THE ZONING ALLOWS ACTUALLY
WHAT CAN BE BUILT. ON A LOT.
AND LOW F. A. ARE AND HIGH
MINIMUM LOT SIZE CAN BE SHAVED
DOWN THAT UNDERMINE MODEST
CONTACT. AT THE STATE LEVEL
INFILL DEVELOPMENT OF JUST
THREE TO TEN UNITS. ARE
PROFESSIONAL ARCHITECTS AND
PLANNERS INSIST THE DETAILS
MATTER. MODEST NEIGHBORHOOD
MULTI FAMILY ZONING IS
NECESSARY BUT NOT SUFFICIENT.
DELIVER MISSING MIDDLE HOUSING
THAT IS MORE AFFORDABLE BY
DESIGN. HE TO PASS BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT TO ENSURE THAT
OUR ZONING CODES MEAN WHAT THEY
SAY AND DELIVER WHAT THEY
PROMISE LET'S INSIST ON TRUTH
AND ZONING. THEN WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
THAT MIGHT BE HERE IN THE
GALLERY. YOU DON'T SEE ANY ROOM.
IN ONE TWELVE ON NO ONE
STEPPING UP THEIR LITTLE SCHOOL
MODERATOR TO THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE PHONE LINES THAT WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU. STATE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL MAY PRESS
FOLLOWED BY THE OWNERS
TELEPHONE KEYPAD. AND THAT'S
ONE QUALITY ZERO. WELL THE
FIRST ONLINE ONCE A- ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. FOR THE NEXT IN LINE
ONE THIRTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME
STATE BEGIN CALLING IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL I'M DOING FROM
UNION CITY THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LINE. ONE SEVEN NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
DOESN'T MATTER THAT WAY OUT
BEHALF OF HIM YOU PARTNERS OKAY
PEOPLE COALITION ACCOMPANYING
FILLED. OUT THEIR CELL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE FORTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON- THIS IS A
PROPER PROBLEM FILLED IN SANTA
CRUZ CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CARIBBEAN SUPPORT. ONE EIGHTY
THREE. HI WARREN WELLS CALLING
FROM BERKELEY CALIFORNIA AND A
MISSING MAN MIDDLE RENTER
CALLING AT THE PORT THANK YOU.
THE. ONE SEVENTY. BUDGET
NUMBERS OUT OF STORAGE- ON
BEHALF TO BE HAVE. STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONE ONE
EIGHT EIGHT SEVEN ONE EIGHT
SEVEN. HI THIS IS MATTHEW LEWIS
ON A HOMEOWNER IN BERKELEY
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION OF HOMEOWNERS NOTICE
SOUTH BERKELEY NOW CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT. WHY IN. ONE
EIGHTY. HI MY NAME IS REBECCA
AROUND CONTINUED ALLEN CALLING
ON BEHALF OF INTER COUNTY CAN
BE AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT. FIFTY
SEVEN. I REMEMBER AS THE
CONTRACT GOING WITH ALAMEDA FOR
EVERYONE CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT. ONE THIRTY TWO. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS TOMMY ADLAI
FROM LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA I'M
A RECENT COLLEGE GRADUATE AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ONE TWENTY TWO. HI AND A BOOK
BY THE CITY CAN'T FIFTEEN HERE
BEYOND THAT THE IN THE SPORT SB
FOUR SEVEN EIGHT. ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN. ONE SEVEN SEVEN ARE YOUR
MUTED. FOUR CONNECT ONLINE. ONE
EIGHTY TWO ONE EIGHT TWO. HI
THERE MY NAME IS NATASHA GORE
CALLING FROM OCTOBER
CALIFORNIANS CONCORD. ONE
THIRTY TWO. RECORDER LINE ONE
SIXTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON
LESTER NUMBERS STARTING LINES
ON BEHALF OF THE PENINSULA
YOUNG DEMOCRATS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THAT BEFORE SEVENTY
EIGHT. LINE. TWENTY TWO. HI MY
NAME OPENS LAWLER WHO PONDERED
STRAIGHT ONLINE- I WANT AND
ONLY LOOK FORWARD STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. FINE. SIXTY
THEY ARE SURE CALLING ON THE OF
THE CUPERTINO ALL STRONG. ONE
NINETY ONE. BOB MADAM REYES
SHARE THIS IS BOB THEY WERE
CALLING FOR PEOPLE SOUTHERN
COMPANY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL. ONE EIGHTY FIVE. HEY
THIS IS TO WITH THE STATE'S
PRIMARY ONE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AB. ONE EIGHTY SIX. HI MY
NAME IS BRAD EWING FROM SANTA
MONICA RETURNING TO THE
ETHICALLY SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY EIGHT.
SEVEN ZERO CAME FROM SCOTT
SALLY CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. ONE
THIRTY THREE. ONE THREE THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO YES
SIR. MICHAEL CRICHTON CAPITAL
DAILY AND I'M CALLING TO REPORT.
NEXT DEADLINE. ONE NINETY ONE
NINE ZERO. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BY WHITE WITH
KATIE PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF THE MODULAR BUILDING
INSTITUTE ALSO IN SUPPORT. ONE
EIGHTY ONE. NEXT GATHERED FROM
OCT THIRD INFANTRY COUNTY YOU'D
BE IN STRONG SUPPORT. ONE
SIXTY. GOOD AFTERNOON MANAGER
MICHAEL GUNNING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF CHAIR WIENER'S BILL. EIGHTY
FIVE. BOB NIELSEN PALO ALTO
AND- BUT FOR EVERYONE CALLING
SUPPORT S. B. FOR TEN YEARS
THANK YOU. ONE EIGHTY NINE AND.
SAN FRANCISCO WILL BE CALLING
IN SUPPORT. ONE SEVEN SEVEN.
THE COMBINED ONE SEVENTY SEVEN.
FOR BOTTOM LINE ONE NINETY FOUR.
HI TELL ME MORE SHAUNA CALLING
ON BEHALF OF WEBSITE FOR
EVERYONE IN LOS ANGELES
CALIFORNIA AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANKS. BERNAL'S FOR THE LINES
IN Q. THANK YOU THEN WE WILL
NOW SEE IF THERE ARE WITNESSES
THAT WE ST TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION- AND I DON'T SEE ANY
IN THE GALLERY AND I DON'T SEE
ANY ON ROOM ONE TWELVE SO WE
WILL AND THERE'S NOT A LEAD
OPPOSITION ARE THEREFORE LET'S
GO TO THE PHONE LINES AND FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TO SB FOUR SEVENTY
EIGHT. THE STATE OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL PLEASE PRESSONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE AND THEN ZERO PLEASE. FOR
THE FIRST ON LINE FORTY SEVEN.
I MEAN BROKEN COALITION FOR SAN
FRANCISCO NEIGHBORHOODS
SPEAKING ON MY OWN BEHALF IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. FIFTY FOUR.
MY NAME IS HOLLY OSBORNE I'M A
RESIDENT OF REDONDO BEACH WE
HAVE TONS OF THREE ON A LOT WE
KNOW HOW TO BUILD THEM WE DON'T
NEED MORE RULES AND REGULATIONS
ABOUT IT SO I'M OPPOSE. THANK
YOU. SEVENTY NINE. NINE SEVEN
NINE. BUT MOVED TO THIRTY THREE.
HELLO CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN YES WE CAN. OKAY BUT WITH
THE FAMILY CAN YOU EAR ME.
HELLO YES YOU CAN BE HEARD BY
THE COMMITTEE. OKAY I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T GET A NUMBER HELLO
THAT'S WHY I AM ASKING- I.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOT IN
GENERAL I WOULD LIKE EMILY
GABEL LUDDY LIBERAL CALIFORNIA.
EXAMPLE NUMBER VALLEY. IT USED
TO. BACK HOME ADOPTED UPCOMING
I'D LIKE TO CORRECT THE RECORD.
SACRAMENTO REMOVED IT FOR QUITE
POLICY IT SUBMITTED ELEMENT
PLEASE JUST LEAVE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION. MODERATE I LISTEN TO
THE RECORDS THANK YOU I AM
OPPOSED TO THIS. ACTUALLY WITH
NO MINIMUM THANK YOU. NINE ONE
TEN. RECALL LIVABLE CALIFORNIA
SB FOUR SEVEN EIGHT CREATES NO
AFFORDABILITY LENIENTLY ZONING-
DEFINITIONS THE CITIES THEY
KNOW BEST OPPOSE SB FOUR SEVEN
EIGHT. PINE FIFTY EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT. WOULD THAT BE ME. YES
YOUR LINE IS OPEN OKAY I DIDN'T
GET A NUMBER EITHER THE PROBLEM
WITH THAT PROCESS. OKAY SO
RIGHT I AGREE THAT THIS SHOULD
BE LEFT TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES
AND CITIES TO DETERMINE THEIR-
DENSITY ON THESE A LOT AND IF
IT'S NOT WORKING IT'S UP TO
THEM. THAT I DON'T THINK IT
SHOULD BE COMING FROM THE STATE
SO I ABSOLUTELY OPPOSE AND
ESPECIALLY SINCE IT'S GOING TO
CREATE MORE MARKET RATE HOUSING
WHICH WE NEED LESS OF. FIND
FOURTEEN. SURELY LOW INTEL TEAM
ALONG WITH L. LIVABLE
CALIFORNIA'S CALLIE OF
CAPITALISM AND UNITED NEIGHBORS
I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. LINE
ONE FIFTY NINE. I STILL THERE
IN THE STANDS VALLEY AND
ANGELENOS WITH TREES ON THE
GLOBAL CAL. AND WE OPPOSE THE
TINY LOT NO IT DOESN'T WORK IN
BALTIMORE THAT'S NOT GOING TO
WORK IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
ONE SIX SIX. THANK YOU MODERATE
MADAM MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
JEREMY THATCHER UP THESE PEOPLE
THE EXTRA TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN OPPOSITION. PINE TWELVE. THE
JUSTICE SECRETARY HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CITIES
FOR LOCAL CONTROL UNITED
NEIGHBORS WEBER CALIFORNIA AND
THIS RESULTS IN A GLIDE PATH
FOR SPECULATORS AND DEVELOPERS
REQUIRING NO INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENT PREVIOUSLY BROWN
USED LOCAL CITY TO KNOW HOW TO
HANDLE PASSED WHERE AND WHEN
AND WHAT TO BUILD THANK YOU.
OPPOSED. ONE EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO SAY ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED AT THE
FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
ONE NINETY TWO. BARBARA B. AND
AVENUE FLA OPPOSED TO FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU. KERN
OFFERED ONLINE IN Q. THANK YOU
THEN WE WILL GO TO COMMITTEE
COMMENTS. I DON'T SEE ANY. IS
THERE A MOTION. MARK WITH
SOMEONE LIKE TO MOVE SB FOUR
SEVENTY EIGHT. I MOVED TO THE
BILL. I HAD A SENATOR SKINNER
HAS MOVED SB FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT
HOW WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL UP COM THE- CONSULTANT
THIS IS SENATE BILL FOR SEVENTY
EIGHT BY SENATOR WIENER THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR IENER.
WIENER I'D BATES NO BATES NO
CABALLERO. HI COPYRIGHT.
COURTESY I'M ACQUIRED. MCGUIRE
I CHOI BOGUE SKINNER FIVE
SKINNER I NUMBER. NUMBER HI WE
CAN SKI HI KELSEY I. SEVEN ONE
SEVEN MILLION. THE DATA BILLS
YEAH VOEPEL GIVE THE GAVEL BACK
TO YOU WHICH I DON'T HAVE OKAY
HERE'S A VIRTUAL GALLAGHER
GALLERY HURDLES EVEN CONSIDER.
I SUPPOSE YES THE BILL THIS OUT
BECAUSE I THINK- CENTER TOGO
NOT- HERE IN ARE COMING BACK.
OKAY WE ARE NOW OUR AGENDA IS
NOW COMPLETE EXCEPT FOR LIFTING
THE CALLS. ANSWERING TO GO BACK
AND I THINK EVERYONE IS HERE
NOW WHO WILL BE VOTING. ON SO
WE'LL START WITH ITEM NUMBER
ONE SB SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR
STERN MADAM CONSULTING CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS SENATE BILL SIXTY THREE
BY SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO.
SENATOR BATES. LOADING PAGE NOT
VOTING. SENATE MCGUIRE. RIGHT
MCGUIRE HI SKINNER. FIVE
SKINNER FIVE WOOD COUNTY. FIVE
WITH HEALTHCARE I FELT. EIGHT
ZERO I VOTERS. THE VOTERS TO
ZERO AND THE BILL AS OUT. NEXT
ITEM TO SB FIVE SIXTY THREE BY
SENATOR ALAN- PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE. THIS IS SENATE BILL FIVE
SIXTY THREE BY SENATOR ALAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE IS
FOR THE ONE. SENATOR BATES.
BATES NO SENATOR MCGUIRE AYE
MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER FIVE
SKINNER WOOD COUNTY OOD COUNTY
ARE. SEVENTY TWO. THE VOTERS
SEVENTY TWO THE BILLS OUT- WILL
NOW GO TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
WHICH IS ITEM THREE A CA TO.
ITEM FOR SB FIVE NINETY ONE AND
ITEM SIX SB. SEVEN TO EIGHT. ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR WHICH
CONSISTS OF FILE ITEMS THREE
FOUR AND SIX CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN TO ZERO SENATOR MCGUIRE
RIGHT MCGUIRE AYE WOOD COUNTY
HI WITH CASKEY I. NINE ZERO
NINE NOTHING IN THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS APPROVED THOSE
BILLS ARE OUT- WILL NEXT GO TO
ITEM FIVE. SB SEVEN SEVEN EIGHT
BY CENTER BACKER PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. THIS IS
SENATE BILL SEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT
BY SENATOR BECKER THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS FIVE ZERO
SENATOR BATES HI BATES AYE
MCGUIRE. MCGUIRE AYE SKINNER HI
SKINNER WOOD COUNTY FINE
BECAUSE I NINE ZERO ET YOU TALK.
OKAY NOT NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
THE BILL IS ACCOUNTS- WILL NEXT
GO TO ITEMS SEVEN SB 6%
RECOVERY ERROR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THIS IS SENATE
BILL SIX BY SENATOR CAFIERO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS THE CURRENT THAT
IS SIX ZERO. SENATOR BATES
ABILITY IT'S NOT BURNING
SENATOR MCGUIRE. I AYE WOOD
COUNTY HI WOOD COUNTY ARE.
EIGHT ZERO ARE THE VOTERS EIGHT
TO NOTHING THAT BILLS OUT- NEXT
ITEM EIGHT SB EIGHT BY SENATOR
SKINNER PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THIS IS SENATE BILL
EIGHT BY SENATOR SKINNER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
THE FIRST AMENDED AND RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT FOR THE
SIX TO ONE SENATE MCGUIRE HI
MCGUIRE AYE WIECKOWSKI HI WE
CASKEY I. EIGHT TO ONE. THE
VOTED EIGHT TO ONE THE BILL IS
OUTS- WILL NEXT GO TO ITEM NINE
S. B. TWELVE BY CENTER MCGUIRE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
THIS IS SENATE BILL TWELVE BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT POTUS FIVE TO TWO
SENATOR SKINNER ALL RIGHT
SKINNER I WOOD COUNTY BY. THE
CASKEY I. SEVENTY TWO. THE
VOTED SEVEN TO TWO THAT GOES
OUT- WILL NEXT GO TO ITEM TEN
SB SEVEN EIGHTY BY SENATOR
CORTEZ A PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. THIS IS SENATE BILL
SEVEN EIGHTY BY SENATOR CORTEZ
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED CURRENTVOTE FIVE ZERO.
SEVEN ACQUIRE HI MCGUIRE AYE
SKINNER ALL RIGHT SKINNER HI
WITH CASKEY HI WOOD COUNTY I.
EIGHT TWO ZERO. BUT VOTERS
EIGHT ZERO THE BILL AS ALEX
WILL NEXT GO TO ITEM ELEVEN SB
SEVEN NINETY ONE BY CENTER
POTENTIALLY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THIS IS SENATE
BILL SEVEN NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR CORTEZ THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION KERR ABOUT IS FIVE
ZERO SENATE MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE
AYE OCHO BOTH. SKINNER FIVE
SKINNER I WOULD CASKEY HI WOOD
COUNTY I. EIGHT ZERO. EIGHT
NOTHING THAT BILLS ELKS AND
ITEMS FOR ALL OF US BEFORE
SEVENTY EIGHT WAS ALREADY
PASSED OUT- SO MADAM
CONSULTANTS AND I CORRECTED
THAT COMPLETES OUR AGENDA
GREAT- SO- THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE WHO PARTICIPATED TODAY
IF YOU ARE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY.
YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
HOUSING COMMITTEE. OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT. AND
WE WANT TO INCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR YOUR- DISSIPATION
PATIENTS TODAY. THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON HOUSING. IS
ADJOURNED.